IT FISCAL REVIEW SEPT TWENTY
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN REST THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC HAS PROVIDED ACCESS. TO
BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCES PATIENT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT BE THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WELL TO BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN. IT IS. 877-226-8163 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN SIX
TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE AND OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUSIC. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEES HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING AND I ASK
ALL MEMBERS TO PLEASE REPORT-
THE THOSE PARTICIPATING THE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MAKE
YOUR PHONE TO COMPUTERS WILL
GREATLY AID IN LIMITING IN THE
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. AND FOLLOW
DIRECTIONS WHEN THEY APPEAR ON
YOUR SCREEN. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. THE COMMENT BE HEARD
AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PRESENT. BEFORE WEEK IT IS.
GOING LET'S LET'S CALL ROLL.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EGGMAN HERE EGGMAN IS HERE
MELENDEZ. PAN WE WOULD NOTE THAT
I AM THE ONLY MEMBER ATTENDING
COMMITTEE TODAY AND WILL CARRY
ON- WILL BE TESTING ALL THE
ITEMS LISTED IN THE- DISCUSSION
ITEM OF THE AGENDA- AND WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH A DISCUSSION
OF SOME OF OUR BUDGET
PRIORITIES. FOCUSING ON OLDER
CALIFORNIANS AND WE'VE ASKED THE
L. A. O. TO INTRODUCE THESE
PROPOSALS LMAO ARE YOU READY TO
BEGIN. YES JERRY BROWN BRAZIL
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THANK YOU SO MUCH INCOME AS WAS
MENTIONED WE WERE ASKED TO READ
THE SENATE DEMOCRAT BUDGET
PROPOSALS ARE REMARKS LARGELY
ROOF- WILL REFLECT WHAT IS
WRITTEN IN THE AGENDA. AND GIVEN
THAT THE PROPOSAL'S ARE
RELATIVELY NEW TO US AND WE MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO ANSWER ALL
QUESTIONS BUT WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
GET BACK TO STAFF MEMBERS AS
NEEDED- I'M SO AS NOTED IN ISSUE
ONE IN THE AGENDA THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS PUTTING WEALTH BACK TO
WORK PLAN PROPOSES TO ONE.
RETURN FUNDING TO TWO THOUSAND
NINE LEVELS TO BEGIN THE
RESTORATION OF BASIC OLDER.
ADULTS INFRASTRUCTURE. AND TO
ESTABLISH A COORDINATED EFFORT
TO RECRUIT TRAIN AND RETAIN
VOLUNTEERS REQUIRED BY STATUTE
FOR SENIOR PROGRAMS SUCH AS
OLDER RIGHT TO PROTECTION IN
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
NAVIGATION ENROLLMENT IN
MEDICARE TAX COUNSELING
ASSISTANCE FOR THE ELDERLY AND
EXPECTORANT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM CLAY COUNTY WHO'S THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SENIORS
COUNCIL AREA ASSOCIATION AGING
OF SANTA CRUZ AND SAN BENITO
COUNTIES. THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU AND I'M ALSO WEARING A
COUPLE OTHER HOUSE TODAY ONE OF
THOSE INCLUDES BEING THE
LEGISLATIVE CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING AND I ALSO HAD
THE PLEASURE OF SERVING ON THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY COMMITTEE
SO IN PUTTING TOGETHER THIS
PROPOSAL SEE FOR A REALLY LOOKED
AT WHAT IS MEANINGFUL AND MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING WHAT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN THE PAST AND WHERE
DO WE START OFF AND MAKING SURE
THAT. OUR THIS PROJECT MOVES TO
SUCCESS SO THE OBVIOUS ONES ARE
WHAT'S BEFORE YOU TODAY
RESTORING SOME PROGRAMS ARE THE
FUNDED IN THE TWO THOUSAND NINE
I GREAT RECESSION THAT HAD
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS AND WERE
ELIMINATED SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
DOLLARS WENT THERE THOSE FALL
INTO TWO CATEGORIES THE FIRST OF
WHICH IS LITERALLY THE ENTIRE
ORDER CALIFORNIANS ACT AND JUST
IN A NUTSHELL I WOULD SAY THE
OLDER CALIFORNIANS THAT. WAS
ACTUALLY THE ORIGINAL MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING BACK WHEN
CALIFORNIA WAS SEEN AS AN
INNOVATIVE LEADER NATIONWIDE IN
EACH PROGRAMS SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT WITH THE CURRENT MASTER
PLAN THAT WE WILL GET BACK TO
THAT STATUS AND WE THINK THE
FIRST STEP IN IT IS JUST GETTING
US BACK TO EVEN GETTING US BACK
TO TWO THOUSAND NINE LEVELS AND
THEN WE CAN BUILD ON THAT.
ALTHOUGH CAL. ACT A VARIETY
PROGRAMS THAT HELP SENIORS IN
DIFFERENT CAPACITIES IN THESE
INCLUDED FOOD DELIVERY I
ACTUALLY GROCERY STORE HOMES
RATHER THAN HOT OR FROZEN MEAL.
I CASE MANAGEMENT THROUGH THE WE
COULD JUST PROGRAM WHICH DID
EXACTLY WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE IT
CONNECTED SENIORS IN NEED TO THE
SERVICES THAT COULD HELP THEM.
GET WHAT THEY NEEDED A DAY CARE
I'M NOT A MEDICAL SOCIAL DAY
CARE FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEMENTIA WHICH OFFERED A LOW
COST OPERATING ON ALTERNATIVE TO
I'LL BE MORE PROFESSIONAL SEA
BASS PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW. THE RESPITE SERVICES
AND A COUPLE OTHER SIMILAR
PROGRAMS. AS THE PARTNER TO THIS
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT RESTORING
OLDER AMERICANS ACT MATCH TO
FEDERAL PROGRAMS AROUND TITLE
THREE B. OR SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
FOR THIS EXERCISE WE'RE CALLING
THAT AGING IN PLACE BECAUSE
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THESE
PROGRAMS DO THEY ALLOW SENIORS
TO AGE IN PLACE AND THEY INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION. OR TRANSPORTATION
TO GET PEOPLE TO THE LOCATIONS
I'VE OFTEN SAID THAT SERVICES
DON'T EXIST THAT NOBODY HAS A
WAY TO GET THERE TO THEM. AND
THEN SOME ADDITIONAL- IMPORTANT
SERVICES SUCH AS LEGAL
PROTECTION. FOR HOME REPAIR
CHORES AROUND THE HOUSE PERSONAL
CARE. IN A VARIETY OF OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT CAN BE CUSTOMIZED
TO AN INDIVIDUAL'S NEEDS AND TO
THE OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE IN
THE- LOCALE THAT THE PERSONS
LIVING AND THAT'S A POINT. WITH
BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS THAT I
REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE. IS THE
TRUE BEAUTY IN THEM IS THERE
FLEXIBILITY IN THAT THESE ARE
STATE AND FEDERAL GUIDELINES
WITH THE LOCAL CHOICE ON HOW
BEST TO MEET THE NEEDS OF YOUR
COMMUNITY. BEST TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
UNIQUE TO YOUR COMMUNITY AND
MAYBE NOT AVAILABLE ELSEWHERE OR
THE CONTRARY. TO THAT AREN'T
AVAILABLE AT ALL IN YOUR MUSIC
B- ANNA DESPERATELY NEEDED A WHY
I LIVE TO POINT OUT ON THIS IS
THAT AND ALLOW. TRIPLE A.'S LIKE
MINE THAT OPERATE IN BOTH A
SUBURBAN AREA IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY VERSUS A RURAL AREA IN
SAN BENITO COUNTY TO CUSTOMIZE
OUR PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT
EACH OF THOSE COMMUNITIES-
UNIQUELY TO THEIR CHALLENGES.
PERSIST TRYING TO DO WHAT IS
DONE IN L. A. COUNTY OR TRYING
TO DO WHAT IS DONE IN. EXTREME
OUR FRONTIER COUNTIES WHERE
SERVICES CAN BE AS BASIC AS
NEEDING SOMEBODY TO CHOP WOOD
FOR SOMEBODY FOR THEIR WOOD
BURNING HOME THAT CAN NO LONGER
DO THAT. THIS FLEXIBILITY IS
JUST ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
PROGRAM SUCCESSES AND WE NEED TO
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN WHAT WE'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF RIGHT NOW IN
TERMS OF NEEDING TO ADJUST
PROGRAMS AND THAT'S THINGS LIKE
THE KOBE. AND THE CODE OVER.
THEM THANK IS SUPER EASY IT IS.
A DIFFERENT PANDEMIC THAT WE
DIDN'T HEAR ABOUT ABOUT SENIOR
SERVICES AND THAT IS LONELINESS
AND ISOLATION LONELINESS AND
ISOLATION IN OLDER ADULTS WAS
ALREADY AT A CRITICAL STAGE WE
CODE HERE. AND WHILE I DON'T
WANT TO REPEAT THE HEALTH
IMPACTS AND THE DEATHS THAT KOBE
YEAH. ALL OF US HAVE HEARD
THOSE. THIS NUMBERS FOR OLD
ROAD. WHEN WANT TO FILE WHAT IT
DID TO ISOLATION AND ENGAGEMENT
OF SENIORS IN THAT IS THAT A
POPULATION THAT ALREADY WASN'T
CONNECTING. DRIVEN FURTHER INTO
COPPER AND FURTHER
DISENFRANCHISE FROM THE
COMMUNITY AT ALL. AND NO PLACES
THAT SCENE BETTER THAN
VOLUNTEERS. AND WE ALSO HAVE
KNOWN AND STUDIES SHOW THAT
NOTHING COUNTERS ISOLATION OR
LONELINESS BETTER THAN
VOLUNTEER. THAT'S THE ULTIMATE
CURE FOR BEING SOCIALLY ISOLATED
OR NOT ENGAGE OR KEEPING ONE'S
MINE SHAR SO I HAD A TIME WHEN
PROGRAMS. ARE WHEN THE DEMAND
FOR THEIR SERVICES ARE GREATER
THAN EVER. AND WHEN SERVICES ARE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED LIKE TAX
ACCOUNTING FOR THE ELDERLY. OR
HEALTH INSURANCE MEDICARE
NAVIGATION THE REQUIRED TO USE
HIGHLY TRAINED PROFESSIONAL
LEVELS ARE. VOLUNTEERS TO
PERFORM THEIR WORK. SUDDENLY ALL
THESE VITAL VOLUNTEERS AREN'T
ABLE TO VOLUNTEER FOR THEIR OWN
SAFETY SO WE END UP WITH THE
DOUBLE WHAMMY IN AND WE'VE HEARD
STORIES- SOME DOCUMENTED ABOUT
PROGRAMS LIKE- BUT IT'S BEEN THE
SAME FORTY TO FIFTY PERCENT. OF
THE VOLUNTEER WORK FORCE-
LOCALLY ONE OF OUR AGENCIES ONE
OF OUR FAVORITE PROGRAMS USES
VOLUNTEERS THE MINOR HOME
REPAIRS THEY'VE HAD TO SHUT DOWN
BECAUSE THEY'RE RETIRED
CONTRACTORS THAT DID THIS WORK
NO LONGER COULD SAFELY. SO THE
VOLUNTEER PROGRAM PROPOSAL IS AN
EFFORT TO COORDINATE THAT EFFORT
TO BRING BACK VOLUNTEERS AND
CONNECT THEM WITH THESE CRITICAL
SERVICES. BUT IT'S TRULY THE
ULTIMATE SOLUTION AND BASS. FOR
FEARING KNOWN AS AN ISOLATION
IT'S ALSO BEEN SHOWN THAT THE
VOLUNTEERS BENEFIT MORE FROM
VOLUNTEERING ON AVERAGE THAN THE
PEOPLE THAT RECEIVE THEIR
SERVICES. SO WE'RE URGING ON
BOTH THESE THOSE THINGS TO BE
FOUND. ON THE DISCUSSION TODAY
DOESN'T INCLUDE FOOD BUT IN MANY
WAYS OUR PROPOSAL FOR MEALS IS
PART OF A RESTORATION EFFORT
ALSO WE KNOW A LOT OF MONEY FLOW
FORWARD WITH KOBE. AND FOOD
PROGRAMS NUTRITION PROGRAMS HOME
DELIVERED MEALS WAS ONE OF THE
GREAT BENEFICIARIES IN
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER THOSE FEDERAL
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO DRY OUT.
AND WHEN THEY DRY OUT THE
SENIORS RECEIVING THESE MEALS
FOR GOING TO BE JUST AS HUNGRY
AS EVER THEY'RE GOING TO NEED
JUST AS MUCH TO ME AS THEY EVER
HAVE. SO WE'RE HOPING THAT THE
AUGMENTIN FUNDING ASK FOR
NUTRITION AND BACK FILLED OUT
FOR THAT'S ABOUT TO BE CREATED
AND ALSO. ADDRESS THE UNMET
HUNGER NEEDS. IN OLDER ADULTS
THAT ALREADY EXISTS. SO WHERE
PROPOSED THIS MULTI. A BUDGET
AUGMENTATION AS OUR IDEA FOR THE
BEST FIRST STEPS FOR MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING OBVIOUSLY THERE'S MANY
COMPONENTS TO IT BUT STARTING
WHERE WE LEFT OFF WHERE WE HAD
SUCCESS SEEMS LIKE A VERY GOOD
STARTING POINT. AND I JUST WANT
TO CLOSE WITH JUST A COUPLE
BLOCKS ONE SAYING THAT FOR YEARS
ONE OF OUR TALKING POINTS HAS
BEEN WE NEED TO ENGAGE. AN
INCREASE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WE NEED TO ELEVATE
THAT CONVERSATION AND WE HAVE
DONE IT WE SHOULD ALL CELEBRATE
THAT WE'RE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
THE LEGISLATURE NO AGING ISSUES
BETTER THAN THEY EVER HAVE
BEFORE SO WE HAVE THAT SUCCESS
BUT UNFORTUNATELY OUR TRUE WORK
STARTS NOW BECAUSE THE CHALLENGE
ISN'T REALLY THIS ELEVATE THE
CONVERSATION. THE CHALLENGE WE
NEED IS TO ELEVATE THE
ENGAGEMENT IN L. E. INVESTMENT
IN OLDER ADULTS IN ADULT
SERVICES SO WE HUMBLY SUBMIT
THIS PROPOSAL FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR FOLLOW QUESTIONS
YOU'D LIKE TO MEET ME TO ADDRESS
THE HAPPY TO ATTEMPT TO DO SO
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CAMPERO YOUR YOUR DEDICATION AND
YOUR ENTHUSIASM. CERTAINLY COMES
THROUGH- SO. HOW MUCH. HOW MUCH
MORE IS TO PRESENT WESTERN
ANYTHING NEW WE'RE JUST GOING TO
CONTINUE TO FUND WHAT WE'VE BEEN
FUNDING AT A AT HIGHER LEVELS.
SO HOW MUCH MORE WILL WE BE ABLE
TO DO AND IS THIS IS A- BUDGET
PROPOSAL CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WE WANT TO BE AS
FLEXIBLE AS POSSIBLE. BUT HOW DO
WE ALSO THEN WORK IN- SWING WHN
SO LIKE SANTA CRUZ. DO THEY FEEL
BECAUSE WELL ABOUT THE PROGRAMS
AS AS PEOPLE DO AND SAN BENITO
COUNTIES AND HOW DO WE KNOW OF
HOW DO WE KNOW THOSE RESOURCES.
ARE ADEQUATELY AND- A FAIRLY
DISTRIBUTED. YEAH THAT'S A GREAT
A GREAT QUESTION- I THINK PART
OF HOW WE DO THAT IS THAT. IS
MAKING SURE THE TRIPLE A.'S
PROVIDE ANNUAL QUARTERLY EVEN
MONTHLY UPDATES AS TO WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WITH THE DOLLARS.
AND FOR PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING
AUGMENTED THAT EXIST THAT'S
REALLY EASY TO DO THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE ALREADY SET. FOR
THE PROGRAMS I'VE BEEN GONE FOR
A DECADE CLASS THAT WOULD HAVE
TO BE REINVIGORATED BUT AGAIN.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE DID. BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND WITH GREAT SUCCESS SO I
THINK ACCOUNTABILITY IS A KEY
PART OF THIS. SHOWING THE IMPACT
THAT WE HAVE ON INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING THE DOLLARS AND HOW
THE DOLLARS ARE. ARE MATCH WITH
NUTRITION IT'S EASY WE CAN
EQUATE THAT SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS WILL RESULT IN ABOUT
SEVEN MILLION MEALS. FOR SOME OF
THESE OTHERS IT'S TRICKIER IN
THAT. GIVEN THE FLEXIBILITY
WHICH WE ALL LIVE IT'S HARD TO
PREDICT SERVICE UNITS BECAUSE
PROVIDING LEGAL SERVICES WHILE
IT MAY HAVE A TEN HUNDRED OR A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR IMPACT.
ON AN INDIVIDUAL THAT MIGHT ONLY
BE ONE SERVICE UNIT THAT GETS
THERE IT'S OBVIOUSLY IT'S MORE
EXPENSIVE. TO PROVIDE SOMETHING
LIKE AND LEGAL ASSISTANCE THAT
IS TO DELIVER A BAG OF GROCERIES
TO SOMEONE'S HOUSE. SO WHEN I
WAS PUTTING THIS TOGETHER I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THAT HOW DO WE
PUT. NUMERALS YOU KNOW HAVE A
BUTTON WIDGET NUMBERS TO EACH
PART OF THIS PROPOSAL AND UNTIL
THOSE LOCAL DECISIONS ARE MADE I
DON'T THINK WE CAN ACCURATELY
PREDICTS. WHAT THE TOTAL
SERVICES BETTER I THINK WE COULD
LOOK AT COST PER UNIT IN THE IN
THE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES AND
COME UP WITH SOME SORT OF
ESTIMATE. ARE PROBABLY BE MORE
UNPRODUCTIVE TO LOOK AT WHAT WAS
DONE A DECADE OR MORE AGO AND
THEN DOUBLE THE COST SIMPLY
BECAUSE INFLATION IS COPPER BABY
DOUBLE THE IMPACT AT THE SAME
TIME. I'M VOLUNTEERS AND I DO
HAVE SOME IDEAS ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF THE WAYS
WE CAN MEASURE POLICY. BOUNCE
HERE ISM IS THE VALUE OF THE
TIME DEDICATE. SO NUMBER OF
VOLUNTEERS IS ONE THING. BUT THE
WORK THE VOLUNTEERS STATUS CAN'T
BE MEASURED AND THERE ARE- TAX
GUIDELINES TO DO THIS THAT
SOMEBODY IS A VOLUNTEER TAX
PREPARER FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S
ESTIMATED AS A TWENTY FIVE
DOLLAR FOR OUR- VALUES. WERE IS
IF SOMEBODY IS JUST DOING
OFFICE. WORK AND MAILING OUT
ENVELOPES OR NOTICES THAT WOULD
BE MORE THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE
CATEGORY SO I THINK THAT MIGHT
BE REALLY INTERESTING. TOOL TO
LOOK AT THE SUCCESS IS MEASURING
NOT JUST THE NUMBER OF
VOLUNTEERS BUT. THE TYPE OF WORK
THAT THEY PERFORM. OKAY ALSO YOU
HOW WE ARE WE ARE A EXCITED THIS
AND THE BUDGET AND- BOTH REALLY
WANTED TO ELEVATE ISSUES AROUND
AROUND AGING THIS YEAR SO- WE
THANK YOU FOR- FOR THIS
PRESENTATION AND THIS ANSWERS
AND THANK YOU TO THE L. A. O.
FOR READING THIS- FOR US AND WE
WILL- WE WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO BUILD ON THE GREAT
FOUNDATION THAT THAT IS ALREADY
OUT THERE. OKAY SO LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO WHICH IS THE
ELECT ELECTRONIC BENEFITS
TRANSFER FUNDS THE PREVENT
PREVENTING AND WE HAVE A CHIEF
DATA STRATEGIST I THINK BRIAN
GILLETTE MISTER LET ME HEAR AND
RATED AGAIN I AM HERE OKAY AND
BEFORE- MISTER JULY- PROCEEDS
WITH THE PRESENTATION I JUST
LIKE TO GET A QUICK OPENER WELL
SURE AND THANKFULLY IT'S HOW AND
THAT CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES SO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO BE HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF DIRECTOR
JOHNSON AND THE DEPARTMENT. TO
OPEN THE CONVERSATION ON OUR
SPRING FINANCE LETTER PROPOSALS
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE BUDGET INVESTMENTS
PROVIDED THIS YEAR THAT HAS
ALLOWED US TO GROW OUR PROGRAMS
AND PROVIDE CRITICAL SAFETY NET
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I'D ALSO LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TREMENDOUS
OPERATIONS ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESSES AND THE WORK BEHIND
THE SCENES THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT- AND
SUPPORT PROGRAMS OF THESE
PROPOSALS THAT YOU'RE ABOUT TO
HEAR WILL PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT
WITH CRITICAL RESOURCES. TO
CONTINUE TATIAN AND- OF OUR FROM
THAT SERVE OUR WHOLE POP. AND
CAL. SO WITH THAT AND I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO MR GILLETTE
WELL. PRESENT ON THE FIRST
OPPOSE ALL ANSWER ANY THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER HER FOR SHE ADDED OKAY
MISTER GILLETT ARE YOU READY TO
GO. I AM THANK YOU SO MUCH- SO
I'M HERE TO TALK TODAY ABOUT THE
ELECTRONIC BENEFITS TRANSFER
REQUESTS- SO CSS IS REQUESTING
ONE FULL TIME PERMANENT
SUPERVISING SPECIAL INVESTIGATOR
TO FULL TIME CURRENT SPECIAL
INVESTIGATORS AND ONE. FULL TIME
PERMANENT ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENTAL
PROGRAM ANALYST. THE COMBAT EVER
INCREASING THIRD PARTY
ELECTRONIC BENEFIT EDT THAT. AS
WELL AS OTHER PUBLIC ASSISTNCE
FRAUD IS NOT BEING INVESTIGATED
CURRENTLY DUE. TO A LACK OF
RESOURCES STATEWIDE. RECIPIENTS
OF CALFRESH IN CALORIES RECEIVE
THEIR IN CASH BENEFITS EDT CAR.
WHICH CAN THEN BE USED AT ATMS
AND POINT OF SALE DEVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. RECENTLY
WE'VE NOTICED THAT THERE'S BEEN
AN INCREASE IN THIRD PARTY STAFF
TO BE T. BENEFITS. THEY'RE BOTH
SKIMMING AD SCANNING SCANNING
IS A FORM OF ELECTRONIC THEFT IN
WHICH A MALICIOUS ACTOR PLACES-
DEVICE ON A POINT OF SALE
TERMINAL THAT CAPTURES THE CARD
INFORMATION CARDS THAT ARE BEING
SCANNED AT THAT TERMINAL.
SKIMMING OCCURS WHEN A MALICIOUS
ACTOR USES SOCIAL ENGINEERING IT
TO MANIPULATE CARDHOLDERS INTO
DISCLOSING THEIR CARD
INFORMATION. IN BOTH INSTANCES-
THAT MALICIOUS ACTORS CAN THEN
USE THE CARD INFORMATION TO
CREATE A CLONE CARTY IN DOT ON
BENEFITS. OFF OF THE RIGHTFUL
CARDHOLDERS ACCOUNT. OVER THE
PAST EIGHTY MONTHS THIRD PARTY
BEST OF AB T. BENEFITS HAS
INCREASED FROM ABOUT. FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH AND
OVER THE PAST TWO. STATE THIS
FOR YEARS TO- IN ORDER MAGNITUDE
OF BETWEEN TWO AND THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PER MONTH IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS. CURRENT
STATUTES IN PARTICULAR AB TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE IN EIGHTEEN TWENTY
THREE THIRTEEN MANDATE THAT THE
STATE REPLACE BENEFITS THAT WERE
STOLEN BY ELECTRONIC MEANS. THE
RESULTING TASK CASH REIMBURSED
REIMBURSEMENTS ARE PAID FROM THE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS. IN
ADDITION FOOD THEFT
REIMBURSEMENTS ARE ALSO ADDED
DUE TO THE OUTCOMES OF YOUR
TICKET RESTAURANTS IN COURT
FINDINGS ARE ALSO PAID FROM THE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS. OFFERED
WHILE FOOD REIMBURSEMENT LEVELS
ARE NOT AS HIGH AS THE CASH SIDE
THE THEFT IN THIS PROGRAM IS
ALSO GROWING. THE PROPOSED
REVISIONS ARE NEEDED TO PREVENT
AND DETER THE THEFT OF U. P. T.
BENEFITS FROM VULNERABLE LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES. ALL PROVIDE
CSS AND DEDICATED ABILITY TO
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS AND
COORDINATE WITH OTHER LOCAL AND
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS
THESE RESOURCES WOULD ALSO LAST
CSS TO ADDRESS THAT IN
INCREASING EBT THEFT IN
CALIBRATION CALTRANS. COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO COUNTIES
AND PROTECTORATE FOR BEING
VICTIMIZED EXPERIENCING LOSS
BENEFITS. THE STAFF WILL MONITOR
INVESTIGATE IN SUPPORT
PROSECUTION THIRD PARTY TO THEFT
AND PUBLIC ASSISTANCE FUNDS AT
THE STATE LEVEL WHILE ALSO
PURSUING ADDITIONAL PREVENTIVE
MEASURES TO REDUCE FUTURE THEFT
ACTIVITIES. WITHOUT HAPPY TAKING
QUESTIONS IN THE HOUSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. THERE THE COMMENTS OF
THIS TIME YOU L. A. L. RYAN
ANDERSON OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE NO QUESTION
THIS. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER WHAT
WHAT WE THINK WHY DO WE THINK
BUT WE HAVE THIS IS PRETTY
MASSIVE UPTICK. TO BE HONEST WE
DON'T TOTALLY KNOW AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING INTO- WE THINK THAT IN
THE PAST PREDOMINANTLY THIS THE
STAFF HAD BEEN. PRIMARILY
INDIVIDUAL ACTORS THAT WERE-
SORT OF ACTING ON THEIR OWN
THERE'S SOME EVIDENCE NOW THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME MORE
COORDINATION GOING ON- SO
THERE'S SME EVIDENCE THAT IT'S
PERHAPS THAT ORGANIZED CRIME
RINGS THAT ARE GETTING INVOLVED
WITH THIS. WE DO HAVE A NUMBER
OF INVESTIGATIONS ONGOING AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND SO WE'RE HOPING
NOT LEARN A LITTLE BIT MORE FROM
THOSE AND HOPEFULLY FRIEDMAN
THAT. CHECK SOME OF THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN- PERPETRATING A
FRAUD SO FAR THAT WILL. BUT
DENTON IN THESE BIG NUMBERS THAT
WE'RE SEEING OKAY AND THE AND
THE NUMBERS ARE THE THEY WERE
REQUESTING. FOR CRIMINALS. FOR
PROSECUTION TO STOP IT OR TO
DETECT IT. SO THE BEES RESOURCES
WOULD SUPPORT A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
SO I'M ON THE FRONT AND THEY
WOULD BE SUPPORTING THAT UPFRONT
INVESTIGATIONS. IT'S HAPPENING
IN THE FIRST PLACE- AND IN SOME
CASES THE PARTICULAR SCANNING
DEVICES IT CAN BE HARD TO LOCATE
WHERE THOSE. DEVICES ARE THE WAY
THEY WORK IS THAT IS THAT PLACED
ON TOP OF THE TERMINAL YOU MIGHT
NOT NOTICE. THAT YOU'D START
SWIPE YOUR CARD THROUGH THEM SO
SOME OF THE WORK IN THIS TEAM
WOULD BE. CONDUCTING ANALYSIS OF
OUR EXISTING DATA TO TRY TO FIND
PATTERNS AND- SEE IF WE CAN
FIND. YOU KNOW WHERE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE HAD AND- AFTER THE CAR
MAKER. YOUR ARTICLE IN PLACES
THAT THEY VISIT IN THE PAST THAT
MAY INDICATE THAT THERE IS ANY
DEVICE THERE- IN SO DOING SOME
OF THAT UP FROM PREVENTIVE WORK
WE MAY BE ABLE TO THEN FIND
THOSE DEVICES AND REMOVE THEM.
TO PREVENT FUTURE PEOPLE FROM.
YOU CAN CHECK INTO THAT. BUT
THEN ALSO ON THE BACK AND
SUPPORTING STATE LEVEL
INVESTIGATIONS ONCE WE DO HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT- THANKS. TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE FULL
RESOURCES TO PURSUE AND
PROSECUTE THOSE CASES. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE IS
THAT YOU MISTER GILLIGAN OR SO
IT'S GOING TO BE A IN THE SHORT
STEP THE DIRECTORS THAT CORRECT
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
DANTE SHORT FROM THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES DIVISION. IS
REQUESTING. STOP SERVICE MANAGER
ONE SPECIALIST POSITION TO
REVIEW AND RESPOND TO STATEWIDE
TRENDS AND EMERGENCY AND WHILE
BEING CONCERNED FOR CHILDREN
INVOLVED ARE TROUBLED- THAT. BY
JENNIFER TRÊN IN THAT AND SOME
OF THE STATE CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF SIX ARE EXPERIENCING
STAYS IN SHELTERS BEYOND THE
MAXIMUM TIME PERMITTED AND MANY
OF HER STAYING AN EXTRA YEAR
TNCS ARE SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM. LONGER THAN
IS NECESSARY TO MAKE THEIR
TREATMENT NEEDS. ONE SIGNIFICANT
OVERSIGHT CONCERNS SUCH AS THESE
ARE IDENTIFIED THE DEPARTMENT
REDRAFT BACK FROM THEIR EXISTING
CRITICAL WORK FOR TEMPORARY
PERIODS TO CONDUCT REVIEWS AND
ANALYSES. AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT IN
RESOLVING THE UNDERLYING ISSUES.
THE THREE DIRECTIONS ARE
CRITICAL TO MEANINGFULLY
PERFORMING OVERSIGHT BUT THEY
ALSO IMPACTS. OTHER WORK IN THE
LIVER OF ALL. IN A POSITION FOR
RECALL. WOULD ALLOW OF TO CREATE
A DEDICATED RESPONSE TEAM THAT
WOULD PLAN FOR AND MANAGE THE
SITUATION AND ALSO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE PROACTIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS MAINTAIN HEALTHY
TEETH GROUT CALIFORNIA. THE
PROPOSAL WOULD SUPPORT
INTERACTIONS WITH HIGH LEVEL
PARTY'S REGARDING SENSITIVE
SUBJECT AREAS AND ALSO MITIGATE
THE COST AND COMPLICATION
THIRTEEN INTERESTING LINE STAFF
ACTIVITIES. IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW
US TO BETTER DETECT ISSUES
BEFORE THEY SPREAD USED DATA
INDICATES REVIEWS MORE
PROACTIVELY DRIVE ACTION TO
DRIVE PROGRESSIVE AND EQUITABLE
CHILD WELFARE POLICY. IN A
DIFFERENT IMPROVING CHILDREN'S
LIVES THE CRUX OF THE FOUR
O'CLOCK TO DECREASE THE
CANCELLATION BILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA RELATED TO THE NEED
FOR SUCH OVERSIGHT. FINALLY
WOULD BE POSITIONED WILL BE ABLE
TO BETTER ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT STAFFING TO IMPLEMENT
DATA INFORMED OVERSIGHT
EVERYTHING INVESTMENT TO ENSURE
THAT THE REPORT THAT MADE
AVAILABLE IN RECENT YEARS. THAT
IS DIRECTLY TARGETING THE
UNDERLYING SYSTEM NEEDS
ADDRESSING IDENTIFIED CAPACITY
AND PRACTICE STAFF. WITH THE
COST OF THE PROPOSAL WILL
ULTIMATELY BE IN DECREASING THE
FREQUENCY OF UNDESIRABLE
EXPERIENCES FOR CHILDREN IN OUR
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. ALTHOUGH IN
THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND SHORT TERM
OUTCOMES MAY APPEAR COUNTER
INTUITIVE AND NOT MORE EFFORT.
MAYBE DISCOVERED AND
INVESTIGATED THROUGH. THE SMALL
CRAFT APPROACH. LOCAL SUPPORT
FOR TERM GOAL OF. AND A-
CRITICAL. IT'S REQUESTED RATE
ARE NOT OF. RIGHT OUT FROM WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL MAN OR VERY
GREAT FOR YOUR CONSIDER. HAPPY
THERE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT FOR. THAT'S
THE GREATEST OF FINANCE- ONLY TO
MAKE IS REALLY TO THE QUESTION
IN THE I. COMMITTEE AGENDA THE
SUN CAN'T COMMIT TO SOMETHING
THAT- RECOMMENDATION ABOUT HAVE
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT
FOR A RALLY- THANK YOU ANGELES
SHORT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- NO CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL WE WOULD AND
JUST COMMENT ON ON THE SAME
ISSUE THAT- THAT FINANCES
COMMENTED ON. WE AGREE WITH A
STAFF RECOMMENDATION COMMENT
THAT IT IT COULD BE A GOOD IDEA
FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO-
CONSIDER BUDGET LANGUAGE AROUND
SOME SORT OF REGULAR- REPORTING
REQUEST- TO ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO BETTER OVERSEE
PROGRESS MADE- TOWARD REDUCING
SHELTERS SHELTER STAYS FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN AND WEBER STATE'S NEXT
YEAR T. P.'S- BUT YOU KNOW AT AS
FINANCE NOTED WE WERE WE WOULD
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE OUT A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT MIGHT BE
POSSIBLE UNDER AND- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SO. SO WHAT ABOUT TWO
SEPARATE ISSUES RIGHT CHILDREN
UNDER SIX AND THEN OVERSTAYS
SOMEONE OVERSTAYS ARE NOT JUST
CHILDREN OVER SIX UNDER SIX BUT
CHILDREN OVER SIX AS WELL AS I
CORRECT. ARE WE JUST TALKING
ABOUT CHILDREN. MIGHT BE A
BETTER AS MEMBERS OF THE U. FROM
THE F. CARE TNCS ARE TEENAGERS
CORRECT. OKAY SO. SO THAT'S
GONNA BE TWO STOP PRESS TWO TO
PERMANENT STAFF POSITIONS. AND
THERE ARE THEY ARE THEY GONNA BE
OVERSEEING THIS. THANK NOT ONE
DOING. THE OVERSTAYS AND ONE
DOING UNDER SIX OR THEY BOTH
GOING TO BE DOING BOTH THINGS.
IT'LL BE DOING BETTER WE'RE AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT WE CAN BE
DOING MORE PROACTIVE KEITH
PREVIEWS AND LOOKING AT THE DATA
MORE PROACTIVELY IN ORDER TO
IDENTIFY TRENDS THAT WE KNOW CAN
LEAD TO SOME OF THE EVERITT
STATE- BUT THEN THE SHELTER
ANYTHING ON IN THE ATMOSPHERE
KIKI- AND THEN- FINDING. WAYS TO
WORK WITH OUR COUNTY TRIED ON
APPLY THOSE TRENDS- AND ADDRESS
THEM. AGAIN IN A MORE PROACTIVE
WAY BUT I WOULD IMAGINE BOTH.
BOTH INDIVIDUALS WILL BE WORKING
WITH US POPULATIONS OKAY. AND
YOU WANT TO PROVIDE ANY COMMENTS
FOR OUTCOME ASSESSMENTS. OF. OF
WATCHING THIS ONGOING. THE BOOK
FINANCING. COULD. YEAH I MEAN WE
WOULD BE LOOKING TO REDUCE THE
OVERALL LENGTH THE STATE TO BE
SURE THAT THE TREATMENT NEEDS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE BEING MET TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
ACTIVE FAMILY FINDING AN
ENGAGEMENT FOR AGAIN FOR OUR
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF SIX
THAT ARE ENDING UP IN OUR
SHELTERS I KNOW WHAT THAT ON
GOING FAMILY MEN AND SUPPORT
LOOKS LIKE FOR THE- FOR THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE. OKAY THE I DON'T
HAVE ANY. IS WITH THIS THAT ITEM
I THINK MY LARGER ISSUE IS I
DON'T. I DON'T KNOW THAT OUR OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM. CAN CAN SUPPORT
ALL ALL OF THE KIDS IN OUR
SYSTEM SO I. ALWAYS JUST WANT TO
KNOW MORE ABOUT ARE THEY NOT
BEING PLACED OR THE STING TOO
LONG BECAUSE THERE ARE NOT OTHER
OPTIONS FOR THEM. AND IF SO WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO CREATE THOSE
OPTIONS AND NOT JUST TRYING TO
REDUCE TIME. BUT PROVIDE THE
BEST OPTIONS AND OUTCOMES THAT
WE CAN AND I KNOW WE ALL AGREE
ON THOSE SAME THINGS. AND I
THINK SOMETIMES ARE LEGISLATION
GOES INTO. EFFECT BEFORE WE HAVE
ALL THE RESOURCES NECESSARY IN
THE FIELD. SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU HAVE ENOUGH. TO BE
ABLE TO DIVERT BOTH DEVELOPED
THE PLACEMENT THAT WE NEED AND
TO MAINTAIN THOSE PLACEMENTS. TO
MAKE SURE THE KIDS HAVE THE BEST
POSSIBLE OUTCOMES. AND YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU CAN DO THAT WITH THESE
TWO STAFF MEMBERS. WELL IN
ADDITION TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE THIRD IS DOING THAT THE
ACTIVE WORK AROUND FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT I THINK
PART OF. THAT ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION IS MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE REALLY ENGAGING A CHILD AND
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO
DEVELOP. AND THOSE PLACEMENT IN
THE ALTERNATIVE FOR CHILDREN
BEING PASSED WITH THEIR OWN
FAMILIES WHERE THEY EXPERIENCED
THE GREATEST ABILITY- IS WHEN WE
IDENTIFY A CHILD AND FAMILY
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE CHILDREN
TO EXPECT THATARE ENDING UP IN
SHELTERS REALLY WANTING TO
IMPROVE. MELENDEZ PROC. AND THAT
WOULDN'T. YOU KNOW THIS THE-
THIS CASE REVIEW TEAM WILL
ENABLE TO FIGHT TRENDS WOULD BE
A FOLKS WITHIN THE THAT ARE ALSO
FEATURE MAKE SURE WORK
INCORPORATING OF THE PRACTICE
AROUND FAMILY. SUPPORT OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
INCREASING SUPPORT FOR CAO WORKS
PROGRAM INNOVATION. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE CRISTINA
MESSA HERE WITH THE WHOLE WORKS
AND FAMILY RESILIENCE BRANCH OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES. I WILL BE PROVIDING
YOU ALL LISTEN BACKGROUND AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
PERTAINING TO OUR REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFFING AND
RESOURCES SEVEN TOTAL STOCK I IN
SUPPORT OF POWER WHICH IS THINK
HOW WORKS I'LL COMMITTEE COUNTED
BELIEVE REVIEW PROCESS. AS A
QUICK REMINDER CAL OR WAS
CODIFIED IN STATUTE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN AS A
LOCAL DATA DRIVEN PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT
FACILITATES CONTINUOUS QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT R. C. Q. Y. FOR
COUNTY MISTER HOWARD'S PROGRAMS.
THIS EQ I PROCESS INCLUDES THE
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS AS WELL
AS SHARING ABOUT COMES AND BEST
PRACTICES THROUGH THE REQUIRED
COMPONENTS. THOSE THREE COMBINED
CORE COMPONENTS INCLUDE PRO
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS IT ALSO
INCLUDES A COUNTY HOW WE'RE
ASSESSMENT OTHERWISE REFERRED TO
AS THE HOUSE YES THEY TOLD. AND
LASTLY EIGHT HOW WORK SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENT PLAN THAT WE. REFER
TO AS THE CONSTANT. HELLO WAS A
RICH IN TO LAW BACK IN THE
TWENTY TWO FIRST YEAR HOWEVER
DUE TO THE ECONOMIC WAS PLACED
ON ONE PODS. AND THEN
SUBSEQUENTLY RE LAUNCHED BACK IN
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THROUGH THIS RELAUNCH EFFORT
SEVERAL ADDITIONAL CHANGES WERE
MADE TO CALOR. THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT OF WHICH BEING THE
MOVE FROM A THREE YEARS WHY
PROCESS FOR CYCLE TO A FIVE YEAR
CYCLE. THROUGH THIS CHANGE THE
DEPARTMENT DEVELOPED BY SEVERAL
COAL WORKS I DO SUPPORT COUNTY
IMPLEMENTATION TO A STAGGERED
APPROACH I TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
MORE ROBUST AS WELL AS
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. AS
COUNTIES LAUNCHED. THE LOCAL
CALIFORNIA SHOULD. IN TERMS
ADDITIONAL. FUNDS AND MOST
RECENTLY WE MARKED THE RELEASE
OF THE COLOR POLICY ALIGNMENT
WORKGROUP REPORT ON APRIL FIRST-
WHICH CAN BE FOUND ON OUR WEB
PAGE. AND THIS IS A WORK GROUP
REPORT INVOLVES SEVERAL
STAKEHOLDERS WHO HELPED INFORM
AND DEVELOP A POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS INTENDED TO HELP
SUPPORT COUNTIES THE COLOR
IMPLEMENTATION. AS A NOTE ON THE
AFRICAN DEPARTMENT PARTICIPATED
SOLELY AS A FACILITATOR GROUP-
IN THE POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE INCLUDED WITHIN THE REPORT I
STEM DIRECTLY FROM THOSE
STAKEHOLDER WORKGROUP MEMBERS.
ADICIONAL EIGHTEEN COUNTY SELF
ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE REFERENCED
EARLY WITH EARLIER AS WELL AS
THE SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT PLANS. R.
D. O. FINAL SUBMISSIONS I
BEGINNING IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THROUGH AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE A REALLY
DEPENDING ON WHICH CALL FOR. THE
COUNTIES FALL WITHIN. DRAFTING
FINAL DUTIES FOR BOTH THE WHOLE
WORKS COUNTY STUFF ASSESSMENT AS
WELL AS ITS COLOR SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENT PLAN A REPORTS CAN
BE FOUND ON OUR WEB PAGE WITH
ADDITIONAL DETAILS. NOTING THE
DIFFERENT DUE DATES BETWEEN
THOSE DIFFERENT COUNTY ASIDE
COHORT. IN ADDITION TO SOME OF
THE OTHER CHANGES THAT ARE
REFERENCED WITH THAT MOVE TO A
FIVE YEAR CYCLE ALSO IMPLEMENTED
THE CUSTOMER SATISFACTION
SURVEY. THE CUSTOMER
SATISFACTION SURVEY IS A STATE
WIDE SURVEY BURKE HOW WORKS
CLIENTS WHO COMPLETED ANY OF THE
FOLLOWING PROGRAM MILESTONES. IN
THE PRIOR MONTH OF RECEIVING
THAT SURVEY MILESTONES INCLUDE
WELFARE TO WORK ORIENTATION.
ASSIGNING THEIR VERY FIRST FIRST
WELFARE TO WORK PLAN AND THEN
LASTLY THE COMPLETION OF THE
FIRST SEMI ANNUAL REPORTING.
ACERBIC WERE DEVELOPED- IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FOLKS OVER
AT MATHEMATICAL TECHNICAL
PARTNER THAT HAS HELPED US
DEVELOP SOME OF THE TRAINING
CURRICULUM BEHIND CALOR. AS WELL
AS PARENT VOICES A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS HOW
WORKS RECIPIENTS. HE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OR
C. TO BE GAY AND OF COURSE OUR
CURRENT PARTNERS. HE AS SURVEY
QUESTIONS. ARE INCLUDED A
VALIDATION PROCESS FROM CURRENT
AND FORMER WORKS RECIPIENTS AS
WELL. THE REQUESTED SEVEN STOP
IN RBC PEOPLE SUPPORT THE
ELECTRONIC DELIVERY OF THESE
SOME OF THE STATE RIGHT SURVEYS
THAT ARE SCHEDULED TO LAUNCH
LATER THIS. FISCAL YEAR IT WILL
ALSO BE ADDITIONAL STAFF ALSO
SUPPORT PETER ROEBUCK AND
ANALYSIS OF THE VARIOUS
FUNCTIONS THAT FEED INTO THE
COMPONENTS THAT I JUST DESCRIBED
A BEHIND THE SCENES WORK PROCESS
FOR COLOR AS WELL AS SECURING A
DEER SHARING AGREEMENTS WITH OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS AND OTHER
PARTNERS ACROSS THE STATE TO
HELP SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
PROCESS. THREE STOCK LOSSES OF A
- SPEAK. AVERAGE FOR COUNTY
COMPARISON OF THEIR COMPANY A
CUSTOMER SATISFACTION
PERFORMANCE THANKS. AND
ANSWERING SUPPORTING OR COUNTIES
IN CONSIDERING WHAT AND HOW THE
DATA. MIGHT INFORM THEIR
COUNTIES PROCESS IMPROVEMENT
EFFORTS. FINALLY YEAH I
REQUESTED STAFF WILL ALSO
SUPPORT AN ANNUAL REPORT
UNTREATED TWELVE MONTHS
STATEWIDE CUSTOMER SATISFACTION
SURVEY DATA RELEASE STATES TO
ALLOW FOR IDENTIFICATION AS WELL
AS DISSEMINATION OF INDIVIDUAL
COUNTY AND STATEWIDE POLICY BEST
PRACTICES. AGAIN THE FIRST
SURVEYS SCHEDULED TO LAUNCH
LATER THIS MONTH AS WELL INTO
JUNE AND JULY OF THIS- OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR. WITHOUT ALL PARTS
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THIS IS A
NEW DOCTOR WITH FINANCE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
OKAY MISTRANSLATIONS HELLO. NO
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
OKAY THAT WAS A GREAT UPBEAT
PRESENTATION WAS VERY IMPRESSIVE
THANK YOU- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I DON'T I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS EITHER SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE- YOU'RE PUTTING THINGS IN
PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE BEST QUALITY ASSURANCE WE
CAN. WE'RE GONNA HAVE UPDATES
THE FIRST TESTER GOING OUT ANNA
AND HOPEFULLY EVERYONE CAN BE
PLEASED WITH THEIR- TONY SOCIAL
SERVICES WHICH IS NOT ALWAYS
WHAT WE HEAR FROM PEOPLE SO.
THANKS THAT WOULD PUTTING SOME
WORK INTO THAT OKAY- MOVING ON
THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE- I
HAVE LISTED ON MY AGENDA MISSED.
THIS LINDA CHAVEZ ARE YOU BACK
WITH THE STAMPEDERS CCO. RIGHT
YES OKAY YES OKAY. RIGHT SO I
WILL BE PRESENTING ON OUR
REQUEST FOR FUNDING TO COMPLETE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COUNTY EXPENSE
CLEAN FUNCTIONALITY- INCLUDING
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS FOR
OUR COUNTY EXPENSE CLAIM
REPORTING INFORMATION SYSTEM OR
WHAT WE COMMONLY REFER TO AS TO
CHRIS- THIS FUNDING WILL SUPPORT
THE VENDOR- CONTRACT SERVICES AS
WELL AS FUNDING FOR LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS THAT WE NEED TO
COMPLETE THE PROJECT. THE FIRST
PROJECT IS AN AUTOMATED SOLUTION
THAT WE USED TO REIMBURSE
COUNTIES FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE SOCIAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ADMINISTERED
THROUGH THE K. ONE FOR
DEPARTMENTS IN THE FIFTY
COUNTIES THE SYSTEM IS LIVE NOW
AND YOU'RE CURRENTLY USING IT
FOR PROCESSING QUARTERLY
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS CLEANS. THE
RESOURCES THAT WE ARE REQUESTING
WILL ALLOW US TO CONTINUE
PROJECT. DEVELOPMENT RECORDS.
BUSINESS PROCLAIM. AND ALSO THE
TESTING THAT'S NEEDED. FOR
COMPLEX BUSINESS RULES FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE- CLEAN PROCESS
AND THAT INCLUDES- PAYMENTS TO
THE COUNTIES FOR AFTER QUARTER
CLAIMS ADJUSTMENTS AND YEAR AND
CLOSE OUT. WHICH I'M NOT BEEN
BUILT INTO THE SECRET PROJECT
YET. HI IN ADDITION RESOURCES
WILL SUPPORT A COMPREHENSIVE
IMPLEMENTATION. ASIAN AND
ROLLOUT AND KNOWLEDGE
TRANSITION- THE MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS- OF THIS YEAR
SOLUTION THAT'S USED BY THE
COUNTIES FOR SUBMITTING THEIR
REIMBURSEMENT CLAIMS. AND THE
FUNDS FOR THE SOLUTION VENDOR
SUPPORT WILL ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
DEDICATED EXPERIENCED
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES TO
CONTINUE WITH THE DEVELOPMENT.
OF THE REMAINING ADMINISTRATIVE-
CLEAN FUNCTIONALITY AND COMPLETE
THE REPLACEMENT OF WHAT HAS
PREVIOUSLY BEEN A VERY MANUAL
PROCESS FOR TREMENDOUSLY LARGE
VOLUMES OF DATA. THE COMPLETION
OF THIS PROJECT IS CRITICAL FOR
IMPROVING THE TYING AND
EFFICIENCY OF PROCESSING
PAYMENTS TO THE COUNTIES
DISBURSING FUNDS AND PROVIDING
THE SERVICES TO OUR PROGRAM
RECIPIENTS. ADDRESS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE IN THE AGENDA
ABOUT- THE- PROJECT HAVING
EXPERIENCED DELAYS OVER THE PAST
FEW MONTHS- AND HOW THE
DEPARTMENT WILL ENSURE THAT THE
PROJECT COMPLETED- BY THE
EXPECTED END DATE OF DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THIS QUESTION THE
DEPARTMENT TEXAS TIMELINE VERY
SERIOUSLY. AND AS STATED IN THE
IN ANOTHER DEPARTMENT HAS
SUFFERED DELAYS DUE TO SOME OF
THE CONTRACT LIMITATIONS EARLIER
ON AND TURNOVER OF BOTH THE
STATE AND CONTRACT STAFF. BUT WE
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
IN THE RECENT MONTHS AND THE
SYSTEM IS IN PRODUCTION I'M LIVE
IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND
SO FAR COUNTIES HAVE SUBMITTED
THREE QUARTERS OF THE CLAIMS
THROUGH THE SYSTEM- WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND TO ENSURE SUCCESS FROM
HERE ON OUT IS THAT WE HAVE
SHIFTED SOME RESOURCES
TEMPORARILY TO ADDRESS. THE
WORKLOAD NEEDS WE HAVE ALSO
PRIORITIZED- COMPLETION OF
CONTRACTS RELATED TO THIS
PROJECT ONE OF THE SPEAKERS TEAM
IS MEETING WEEKLY WITH THE
VENDOR TO MANAGE THE PROJECT
DELIVERABLES AND ESURE THAT
WE'RE ALL MEETING THE
MILESTONES. ARE WE ARE ALSO
CLOSELY MONITORING THE PROJECT
AT ALL LEVELS INCLUDING
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP AND WE ARE
IN CLOSE COLLABORATION WITH OUR
OVERSIGHT AGENCIES- INCLUDING
COUNTY JUST AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AS WE MOVE THROUGH.
THE REMAINDER OF THE PROJECT
APPROVALS TO ENSURE THAT IT'S
COMPLETED BY DECEMBER. W ALSO
HAVE SEEN THAT SECREST HAS
IMPROVED THE TIME DURATION
REQUIRED TO PROCESS ALL OF THE
CLAIMS THAT HAVE BEEN COMING
THROUGH AND SO FAR. THE FEEDBACK
ON THE WEB PORTAL- AND USER
INTERFACE HAS BEEN VERY
POSITIVE- INJURED OF OUR- WITH
ACCOUNT. WELL HI THERE ANY OTHER
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. ARGININE DR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I KNOW FOR
THE CONCERNS AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MAKE SURE. YES I'M WE'VE
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL-
AND YOU KNOW JUST TRACKING
PROGRESS OF THE PROJECT BUT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS RAISED AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU OKAY. THANK
YOU MICHELLE SO IT SOUNDS LIKE
BUT WE WERE LATE TO LUNCH BUT
NOW IT INDEED WE HAVE LAUNCHED
WHICH MAKES YOU FEEL SECURE.
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO COMPLETE
THE PROJECT NOW THAT IT'S
LAUNCHING THINGS ARE IN PLACE
AND COUNTIES HAVE BEEN ABLE TO.
INTERFACE WITH THE SYSTEM. AS
OUR UNDERSTANDING OKAY THANK YOU
SPEAK TO THE ISSUE OF THE- YOU
MAY BE LEFT WITHOUT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE LAST SIX MONTHS DID
YOU ADDRESS THAT ISSUE- IT WAS
THAT WE HAD SOME TURNOVERS
STAFF. BOTH ON THE VENDOR SIDE
AS WELL AS ON THE STATE SIDE SO
WE WE'VE MADE SOME- REDIRECTION
OF STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE ADEQUATE STAFFING TO
SUPPORT THE PROJECT. SO THAT'S-
YOU KNOW IT IT WAS A SHORTAGE OF
STAFF THAT HAD OCCURRED RIGHT WE
ARE DOING THE BEST THAT WE CAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
ADEQUATELY RESOURCE TO. GET US
THROUGH THE FINISH LINE. OKAY IT
IN SOUND YOU DON'T SOUND SURE ON
THAT LAST PART. THIS IS WHAT WE
FEEL IS NECESSARY TO COMPLETE
THE SEGMENT OF THE- PROJECT WE
HAVE THE STOCK. YOU KNOW IT YEAH
I KNOW WORKFORCE TODAY
CONTINUATION OF THE FUNDING
THAT'S NEEDED TO ALLOW THE-
PROJECT OKAY. OKAY- AND THE
STAFF THAT WE HAVE CAN PROVIDE
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
EXPERTISE THAT WE NEED. CORRECT
YEAH- THE AGENDA HAD MENTIONED
EARLIER ON THERE WERE. SOME
DELAYS DUE TO HAVING TO GAIN
THAT EXPERTISE FOR THEM THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM SO JUST
THROUGH THE LESSONS LEARNED
SWEET OVERCOME THAT HURDLE AND-
WE ARE ABLE TO- WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR VENDORS.
TO GET- THE NECESSARY- TATIAN
THAT WE'VE HAD SO FAR WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN. FINISH
LINE IN THE MONTHS TO COME OKAY
ALL RIGHT WELL WE'LL BE WATCHING
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUED NUMBER
SIX MIGRATING DATA FROM LEGACY
SYSTEMS SO I HAVE A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR KEVIN GAMES HERE TO.
PRESENT TO US. GAINES ON THE S.
S. YOUR LICENSE REVISION- IT'S
OVER HERE PROPOSAL REALLY
QUICKLY WELL WE'RE ASKING ON
JUST OVER MILLION DOLLARS IN
CONTRACT DOLLARS AN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO SUPPORT. ON THE ISSUE
BOSTON SIX VIOLENCE AND WE WILL
PROJECTS SO MY- IN CLEAN. ON
DOWN FROM EIGHTY DIFFERENCE
LEGACY OF LICENSING SYSTEMS-
STAGING. WHERE WE- FOR. TO BE
FACILITIES MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
WHICH WAS APPROVED YOU NEED
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AS WE
APPROACH. BOTH OF THEM MAJORITY
OF THE WORKERS ALREADY MAKING.
ASIAN THE CLEAN UP WELL YEAH
SEVEN SYSTEMS HAS BEEN COMPLETED
WE JUST NEED THESE IN FUNDS
ADDITIONAL SALARY TO GO. THE
CLEAN UP IN MY OF THE EIGHTH.
THIS PRETTY MUCH ALL OF ON ALL
THERE IS TO. ANSWERING QUESTIONS
THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
PART OF FINANCE. THANK SHARE
DATA CENTER PERMANENTLY ADD
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SHORT. WE'VE REVIEWED
THIS PROPOSAL AND DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS. I DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS EITHER WITH DIRECT TO
THE POINT WE APPRECIATE THAT
MOST GINS. OKAY LET US MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
STRENGTHENING EMERGENCY CAPACITY
AND CAPABILITIES. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JEREMY CHAPLIN AND LET
CHIEF OF THAT DISASTER SERVICES
RANCHER ONE POINT FROM THE
SOCIAL SERVICES- DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES REQUESTING
TWELVE PERMANENT POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT THE DISASTERS BRANCH AND
ADDRESSING ESSENTIAL MASS CARE
AND SHELTER FUNCTIONS FOR
EFFECTIVE DISASTER PLANNING
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
OPERATIONS. THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES WILL STRENGTHEN OUR
LEADERSHIP OVERSIGHT AND
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS AND
EXPAND OR BUILD OPERATIONS TO
SUPPORT THREE REGIONAL AREAS
WHICH ARE CURRENTLY MIMIC THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR OFFICE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES OF THOSE THREE REGIONS
WOULD BE OUR INLAND COASTAL AND
SOUTHERN REGIONS. THESE
POSITIONS WERE A LOT WITH THE
BASE FIVE EMPLOYEES DIRECTLY IN
THE SOUTHERN REGION TO RESPOND
MORE QUICKLY TO DISASTERS THE
REMAINING POSITIONS I WOULD
EXPAND OUR RECOVERY OPERATIONS
TO LEVERAGE OUR STATE AND
FEDERAL DISASTER ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM LIKE FOR DISASTER CASE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDE
SERVICES DIRECTLY TO DISASTER
SURVIVORS ACKERMAN BANKS. ARE
STATES THAT WOMEN ARE GRANT
PROGRAM- THE TRANSITIONAL
SHELTERING ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS OUR PEOPLE
REIMBURSEMENTS. WITH PRIMORYE.
LASTING LONG AND MORE RE. I'M
BEING. MORE RESOURCES FROM THE-
OR NEEDED TO PROBABLY. DOCUMENT
ALL OF THE COSTS REPLY FOR ALL
THE PEOPLE REIMBURSEMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT WE IS THE STATE OR
COPING AS MUCH OF THE COST AS
POSSIBLE. I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE STAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THIS IS JEAN DR WITH
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU OKAY AND
FELLOW. YOUR NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS PROPOSAL AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU AND SO IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
AND DEVELOP SIX MASS CARE AND
SHELTER EXERCISES ANNUALLY.
COMPLETE TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
CRITICAL SHELTER ASSESSMENTS TO
REALLY GOING AROUND THE STATE
AND TO THE- YES REGION'S OUT
THERE ALREADY THERE. AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE SOCIAL
SERVICES IN PLACE ON THE GROUND.
WHEN A DISASTER OCCURS.
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
CHARGED WITH YES UP SIX MEMBERS
EXPORT FUNCTION FOR MASCARA
SHELTER SO WHILE CARILLO YES
WORKS WITH THE COUNTY EMERGENCY
MANAGERS WE WORK WITH THE COUNTY
MASTER COORDINATORS- SO THAT TO
ENSURE THAT WHEN THE DISASTER
DOES OCCUR. THAT WE HELP THEM
THE COUNTY IS NOT JUST POSSIBLE
SEPARATE SHELTER AND SUPPORT
THEIR NEEDS WHEN NECESSARY. OKAY
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHOULD
THE PRESENTATION ALL RIGHT- I'M
MOVING ON TO REFUGEE PROGRAM
SPIRO OPERATION AND SUPPORT
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE EGGMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALI AND
I CAME UP WITH AND I AM THE
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION BRANCH
CHIEF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US TODAY I
WILL BE PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW
OUR REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL-
DEPARTMENT POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT AND YOU
COME OUR POPULATIONS. BERMAN IS
REQUESTING APPROVAL OF EIGHTEEN
FEDERALLY FUNDED POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF THE
REFUGEE PROGRAM ZERO. THAT
COORDINATES AND OVERSEES REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA. THE EXPANSION IS
NECESSARY GIVEN THE RECENT
INCREASE IN AFGHAN RIVALS AND
EXPECTED FUTURE INCREASES IN
FEDERALLY SUPPORTED REFUGEE
POPULATIONS. SPECIFICALLY THESE
WITH THESE POSITIONS WILL ALLOW
THE REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT PROGRAM
TO SUPPORT THE INCREASED
CASELOADS AND CASH AID WORKFORCE
AN EDUCATIONAL SUPPORTS THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES. THAT
FACILITATE SUCCESSFUL
RESETTLEMENT AND INTEGRATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S NEWLY ARRIVED
REFUGEE POPULATION. THE BUREAU'S
WORKLOAD INCLUDES IN INCREASING
GRANT OVERSIGHT POLICY
INTERPRETATION TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT RESPONSIBILITIES. AS
WELL AS SUPPORTING THE EXPANSION
OF THE UNACCOMPANIED REFUGEE
MINORS PROGRAM. THE BUREAU
CURRENTLY CONSISTS OF FOURTEEN
AUTHORIZED POSITIONS FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE REBUILDING OF THE
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE STATE
WITH THESE ADDITIONAL STAFF.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE REQUEST THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. PERSON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS TIME.
HELLO I NAY ANDERSON LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE NO QUESTION
THIS TIME OKAY. AND IT ARE WE
HAVE NOT BEGIN TO SEE THE
REFUGEES COME FROM- UKRAINE
RIGHT NOW WHICH IS MOSTLY
AFGHANISTAN IS THAT WE'RE STILL
WORKING WITH. YES THE REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT NETWORK IS STILL
WORKING WITH THE AFGHAN OF
RIVALS WE HAVE SEEN OVER. WE AT
THE MEDIA'S REPORTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND UKRAINIANS THAT
HAVE ENTERED INTO THE UNITED
STATES FROM THE SOUTHERN BORDER
HOWEVER- WE THIS IS OUTSIDE OF
THE REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT PROCESS
SO WE ARE MONITORING IT CLOSELY-
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT AND
COORDINATE- ONCE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. HAD TURNS ON THE
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT SUPPORT FOR
THESE POPULATIONS MANY OF THESE
ARE COMING IN ASKING MEDICARE
ENROLLEES. AND THEREFORE ARE NOT
CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT SERVICES WE
DO EXPECT THAT CONGRESS MAY
DECIDE TO SUPPORT THEM IN THE
COMING WEEKS OR MONTHS. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN
THIS IS A ROUTE WERE REQUESTING
THAT YOU ACCEPT FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR THIS PROGRAM. CORRECT YES
THAT'S RIGHT OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT WORK OKAY MOVING ON
HOME CARE FUND LOAN FORGIVENESS. YEAH COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
DIVISION SO ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL JUST SOME- IS FOR
FORGIVENESS OF REMAINING ALONE I
WAS AMAZING THE WHOLE CARE FINE
. AND THE INCEPTION OF THE WHOLE
CARE SIR FROM BACK. THIS IS YOUR
CHOICES LIKE SEVENTY ALSO
PROPOSAL- THE WHOLE CARE. A WELL
BOUNCE. MILLION I'M OTHERWISE BE
TRIED TO STATE JOURNAL FUND ALL
. THE SO- I WAS WE ARE GENERAL
LEDGER CALLS AND OF BALANCE.
ASSEMBLY- EXPANDED RATHER FROM-
IAN CALDERON HOLD KERRY AND HOLD
YOUR- IS FALLING ON THE LOCAL IN
THE- WE'RE DOING- ELSE FIGURE
OUT WHY AND WILL BE ON WITH THIS
- THIS IS TO. PROVIDE SOME
INSIGHT THAT- SIGN. IN ONGOING
SALAS. OKAY SO WE DON'T KNOW WHY
BUT WE'RE GONNA FIGURE OUT YES.
OKAY OKAY- THE PERMANENT FINANCE
. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN ON WITH THE
DIFFERENT OF FINANCE SOMETHING
TO THIS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY.
OKAY LMAO. THANK BROWSER WITH
THE NLESS ANALYSTS THIS- AS WE
NOTED I'M SORRY YOUR STAY THAT
THE I REQUEST YOU FORGET THE
GENERAL FUND MONIES MAINLY
BECAUSE THE ADMINISTRATION IS.
PROJECTING A DECLINE IN FEE
REVENUES IN THE BUDGET YEAR
RESULTING IN THE FIND NOT HAVING
ENOUGH- DOLLARS TO MAKE LOAN
PAYMENTS- FOR CONTEXT AND THE
FUND WAS ABLE TO SUSTAIN SOMEONE
PAYMENTS IN THE PAST- BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE BASED OFF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROJECTIONS
THIS IS NO LONGER FEASIBLE- WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
OUT TO THE ADMINISTRATION. I'M
TRYING TO GET MORE INFORMATION
ON THE REASONS BEHIND THAT THE
REVENUE DECLINE BUT ALSO- THE
FEASIBILITY OF CAUSING PAYMENTS
VERSUS FORGIVING THE LOAN ALL
TOGETHER AND TRY TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE IMPLICATIONS OF
THE PA'S ALTERNATIVE- JUST GIVEN
THAT. THE ASSUMED REVENUE
DECLINE IS A PROJECTION SO IT
JUST GIVES US ANOTHER YEAR TO
REALLY GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHETHER THE
DECLINE THAT WE MAY BE
EXPERIENCING TO DATE IS MORE OF
A SHORT TERM DECLINE OR IS IT
REALLY A LONG TERM ISSUE- AND
THEN SOMETHING ELSE THAT- WE
WOULD SUGGEST. IS THAT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THIS IS A LONG TERM
SOLVENCY ISSUE THE LEGISLATURE.
ALSO MAY WANT TO CONSIDER. I'M
HAVING TO DEPART REPORT BACK
NEXT YEAR TO THE STOCK. I IT AND
- SALUTE- SO THAT THE FUNDS CAN
BE SELF SUSTAINING GOING FORWARD
AS ORIGINALLY INTENDED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
GAINS YOU HAVE ANY OPINION ABOUT
PAUSING. PURCHASES SPENDING.
MMHM AGAIN OUR OUR- OUR STRONG
REMITTANCES IS. HOWEVER BOMB WE
CAN- WE CAN CHANGE OUR WHOLE CAN
AND AROUND YES- THE L. L. OFFICE
- I WOULD SAY TO- FIGURE OUT AS
WE PRESENT OUR WE UNCOVER AND
PRESENT- WHEN YOU THINK IT MAY
BE OUR OUR ONE TIMER STRUCTURAL-
ISSUES IN THE PROGRAM THAT WOULD. YOU KNOW SANDERS- AS A- IT'S A
THIS ALSO. WE'LL WE'LL WORK WITH
THEM TO CENTER. INSTEAD OF
SOLUTIONS AFTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SPEAKING AND I WOULD I
WOULD HAVE STAFF OF WE COULD FOR
UP ON THIS AND JUST- THE SEE IF
THE POSH MORE WILL ACTUALLY OUT
OF THERE'S JUST. DEFICIT THE
IMPACT BITS GOING TO BE ON GOING
AND IF IT IS GOING TO BE ONGOING
THEN HOW DO WE HOW DO WE LOOK AT
THAT OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MICHIGAN'S OKAY. NOW
I THINK WE'RE MOVING ON TO SOME-
TRUMPCARE POLICY SUPPORT
PROGRAMS ISSUE NUMBER TEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HERE AGAIN THIS IS
LIVING HI MY LAN DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION AND I WILL BE
RESPONDING TO ISSUE NUMBER TEN
AND HAPPY TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS
AT THE END. AS A QUICK REMINDER
AS OF JULY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE GOVERNOR APPROVED
THE SIGNED AND SIGNED THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT ACT
APPROVING THE TRANSFER OF CHILD
CARE AND DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO CBS. AS A RESULT
THE NEW DEAL FAST NOW BEEN
DISTRICTS EIGHTEEN HEALTHCARE
SUBSIDY PROGRAMS THAT SERVE OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS AND GROWING
FOLLOWING THE TRANSFER OF THE
PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES THE NEW
ESTABLISHED HEALTHCARE AND
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION TRANSFERRED
SIXTY NINE POINT FIVE POSITIONS
FROM CP TO RECEIVE EIGHTEEN
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS. WHILE
THESE RESOURCES HAPPEN SUPPORTED
THE NEW DEVELOPMENTS FROM THE
DIVISION'S INITIAL BUSINESS
NEEDS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
TRANSFER PROGRAMS THE DEBATE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS AYE NEXT AND THE
FIGHT THE NEEDS FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO BELIEVE ME EFFORTS
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW WHICH INCLUDES ALSO
THE ADMINISTRATION OF A NEW
GRANTS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS. PROGRAM FUNDED FOR TWO
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AS A
RESULT THE BUDGET RESULTS REYES
THE BUDGET REQUEST SUMMARY
REQUEST NINETEEN POINT FIVE
POSITIONS AND SIX MILLION AND
GENERAL FUNDS. PER YEAR
THROUGHOUT TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE TO CONTINUE TO
CONTRACT WITH A VENDOR. TO ALLOW
FOR CHILD CARE AND ELECT TO
DIRECT DEPOSIT. I WILL NOW
ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS AND
PROVIDED SO AS AN UPDATE TO THE
CURRENT POSITIONS WE HAVE NOW UP
TO SIXTY NINE POINT FIVE
POSITIONS THAT TRANSFER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HE CDSS BUT CHAO CARE
NEW DEVELOPMENT DIVISION SIXTY
ONE POINT FIVE ARE FILLED WITH.
EIGHT ARE CURRENTLY VACANT.
HOWEVER THOSE WERE FIELD TO DO
THE PROMO WITH THIS NEW DIVISION
FOR A FARM OR ALL IF YOU. WE
ARE. TO THAT EIGHT VACANCY. OF
OUR THEM THE ADDITIONAL POSITION
PROVIDED TO SEE THAT- KID
MINISTER THE PROGRAM TO ARE. AND
ARE CURRENTLY VACANT AND WE HAVE
OPENS. THE ADDITIONAL PER
REQUEST WILL FROM WORK NOW
CURRENT SUPPORT BY FROM.
RESOURCES DO TO PASS AUTHORIZED
NOT TRANSFER TO THE BUSINESS
NEEDS THAT CANNOT BE THAT CANNOT
BE IDENTIFIED PRIOR PRIOR TO THE
TRANSITION AND DUE TO THE NEEDS
OR LEADERSHIP POSITION OVER A
TEAM THAT WAS SPLIT BETWEEN
DEPARTMENTS STUDENTS TO
TRANSITION ALSO. DETAILS OF THE
WORKLOAD ANALYSIS IS ALSO
PROVIDED IN FOR FIFTY CHANGE
PROPOSAL. THERE'S ALSO A
QUESTION IN REGARDS TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS PROGRAM
AND WHETHER THAT POSITION- WAS
WAS TRANSFERRED FROM CBTC DSS.
YES THE ONE POINT OH POSITION
WAS PROVIDED FROM CP FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM IT
WAS FIELD WHILE AT CV BOARD TO
RE DIRECT WORK PRESCHOOL
DEVELOPMENT GRANTS AT RENEWAL
PVG ARE WHEN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT WAS- REFUNDED- WAS SWEPT
DURING RIGHT BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. THAT THIS POSITION TO
ANSWER TO CDSS ON JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND CONTINUES
TO BE DEDICATED TO CSS P. G. R.
DUTIES SUCH AS- IN HOUSE MARKS
AND SUPPORT LOCAL. COUNCILS
SAPRISSA INSTEAD OF TO HELP YOU
SEE WORK AS- WILL NOT TRANSFER
SEE THE APPS AND- THE LOCAL THE
PER. THAT TRANSFER SKILL IN DATA
FOR SERVICE. ALSO A QUESTION IN
REGARD TO THE ELECTRON PAIN
SYSTEM BY S. AND SAID ONLY TIME
PAYMENTS SYSTEM WOULD BE IN
PASCAL THIS WILL BE DEVELOPED BY
FISCALE SCO AND PAST TEO
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO ADDITIONAL
DETAILS OR TIMELINES FOR THIS
IMPLEMENTATION- IN ADDITION THE
APPS. ESIO HAS A HYBRID E. F. T.
PROCESS THIS PROCESS REQUIRES
SCO TO APPROVE THE SCHOOL FIRST
THEN AUDITED APPROVED THE
PROCEDURES AND HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT INFORMATION.
TECHNOLOGY GROUPS DEVELOP A FLAT
FILE FOR EXAMPLE THAT CASSIDY
ABSOLUTELY TO THE SCO THE MAIN.
MAINFRAME FOR AUDITS THE PROJECT
COST FOR THIS EACH OF THESE
IMPLEMENTATIONS IS ABOUT SIXTY
FIVE K. AND COST OF ONGOING
AUDITS. EACH IMPLEMENTATION
COULD TAKE- I'M ABOUT NINE
MONTHS OR SO THE MINIMUM TO GET
THIS GOING. A MINUTE AND TURN IT
OVER TO BRIAN TO LET THAT BE
DIRECTOR OF THE RESEARCH AND
AUTOMATIC AND DATA DIVISION TO
FIGHT. TO THE NEXT COUPLE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU LOU BAY ARE
LET OF FROM THE RESEARCH ARMY
AND DATA DEBATE- SO I'M GOING TO
RESPOND TO QUESTIONS FOR- ABOUT.
THE NEED FOR THE INTERAGENCY
AGREEMENT IN THE TIMELINE FOR
THE EXISTING CITY SYSTEMS- AND-
SO THE COW STARK SOLUTION- HAS
THREE COMPONENTS THAT ARE BEING
DEVELOPED CONCURRENTLY BUT MAY
HAVE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
TIMELINES THE FIRST CONSISTENT
COMPONENT IS A CONSUMER
EDUCATION TOOL THAT WILL LAUNCH.
AN INITIAL VERSION THIS SUMMER.
THE SECOND COMPONENT IS THE
ENTERPRISE DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WILL GOVERN HOW DATA FLOWS
WITHIN THE CHILD CARE LANDSCAPE
IN BETWEEN OTHER PROGRAM AREAS.
WE HAVE ENOUGH IN INITIAL
FRAMEWORK FOR THIS FUNCTIONALITY. HELLO THE OTHER COMPONENTS.
THE THIRD COMPONENT OUT OF FROM
OF TELLS WILL FOCUS ON THE DATA
COLLECTION ADMINISTRATIVE
BUSINESS PROCESS SEEKS TO
REPLACE THE FUNCTIONALITY OF THE
EXISTING CITY LEGACY SYSTEMS.
YES IS CURRENTLY IN STAGE TO THE
ALTERNATIVE ANALYSIS PHASE OF
THE PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SOLUTION. YES
THAT'S THE CONTRACTED WITH
ACCENTURE TO HELP WITH BUSINESS
DISCOVERY AND PRODUCE THE
REQUIRED DOCUMENTATION TO
CAPTURE THE BUSINESS
REQUIREMENTS WHILE WE ARE STILL
FINALIZING THE WORK PLAN BUT THE
CENTER. WE EXPECT THAT THIS
PROCESS WILL BE COMPLETED
SOMETIME IN Q. THREE OF STATE
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND SUBMIT AS TO A- TO
SEE AT FORK WILL THAT TIME. AT
THAT POINT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A BETTER ESTIMATE OF THE
REMAINING TIME LINE BUT THE NEXT
STEPS WILL BE COMPLETION OF THE
PRODUCT OF A LIFE CYCLE AND
RUNNING- PROCUREMENT TO IDENTIFY
A SOLUTION- MEETING CSS IS T.
ISN'T TECHNICAL NEEDS. AND THEN
EXECUTING ON THAT PARTICULAR
TRIP BY THE SOLUTION AND BRING A
BETTER ON BOARD FOR THE DESIGN
CONFIGURATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION. WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY CDT AND- JAZZ TOGETHER
TECHNICAL EXPERT. THROUGHOUT
THIS PROCESS. AND IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPEDITE. THIS
PRODUCT IS A TOP PRIORITY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT I'M SO WE ARE WE
CAN WORKING HARD TO MEET THE
ESTABLISHED OUTLINES THE
EXISTING CITY SYSTEMS ARE
COMPLEX THE BILL THIS AFTER IS
TO STAND UP A NEW SYSTEM
LEVERAGING OFF THE SHELF
SOLUTIONS WHEN POSSIBLE WHICH
ALLOWS TO UNIFY THE ARCHITECTURE
BUT ALSO RE ENGINEERING-
EFFICIENT BUSINESS PROCESSES. AS
A RESULT WE HAVE PLACED MORE
EMPHASIS ON UP FRONT PLANNING
WHICH WE ANTICIPATE WILL SAVE
TIME ON THE BACK AND- WITH
REGARDS TO- CONTINUING TO ACCESS
THESE SYSTEMS. THE TIMELINE FOR
THAT WILL DEPEND ON CHANGE
MANAGEMENT PROCESS HOW QUICKLY
WE ARE ABLE TO GET USERS TO
ADAPT AND PRACTICES. WE PLAN TO
EXPLORE PHASE APPROACHES FOR
ROLLOUT WHICH COULD MEAN THAT WE
ATTAIN INDEPENDENCE PARTS OF THE
CITY SYSTEMS ON DIFFERENT
TIMELINES. WE WILL ENGAGE WITH
CD AS WE ASSESS WHAT IS MOST
AFFECTED ARE TO ASSESS WHAT IS
MOST EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT- OF
THE SYSTEMS TO TRANSITION FIRST.
FINALLY I WOULD NOTE- THAT IT IS
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT SEED
INTENSELY CONTINUE TO USE THESE
SYSTEMS FOR OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
THEY RUN IT WAS NOT TRANSFERRED
OVER TO CSS. AS PART OF HELP. WE
WILL COME. THE COSTS OF THE
PROGRAM TO THE STATUS QUO-
MAINLY CONTINUING TO USE THE CD
SYSTEMS- TO THE ALTERNATIVE
OPTIONS. THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
WITH THAT COMPARISON IS THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL BE PROVIDING
FUNCTIONALITY THAT IS NOT
CURRENTLY INCLUDED ARE POSSIBLE
WITH THE EXISTING LEGACY SYSTEMS
WHICH COULD MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT
MORE DIFFICULT TO CONDUCT AN
APPLES TO APPLES COMPARISON.
THERE IS ONE FINAL QUESTION
REGARDING THE ONGOING COSTS AND
THE CAL SPARK SOLUTION- AT THIS
POINT WE DON'T HAVE AN ESTIMATE
OF WHAT THOSE COSTS MIGHT BE.
WONDERING COSTS WILL DEPEND ON
THE SOLUTION THAT IS ULTIMATELY
IDENTIFIED. WILL BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE TONIGHT ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AS SOON AS THIS
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT WE SHOULD KNOW
MORE ABOUT THAT ONCE WE COMPLETE
OUR- ESTIMATE BASED ON THE
PRODUCT. LIFECYCLE AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU SHARED TOMORROW
WHETHER DEPARTMENTS FINANCE
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME.
OKAY HELLO. THANK THEIR CORTEZ
L. A. L- NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
IF YOU. HI RIGHT WITH A LOT OF
MOUTHFULS OF A LOT OF ACRONYMS.
MY GOODNESS BUT WE'RE WE'RE
ACCEPTING FEDERAL MONIES TO MAKE
SYSTEMS WORK BETTER AND ALIGN
WITH CD IN IN A BETTER WAY. HERS
ARE TAKE AWAY A- OKAY OKAY THE
ONLY THING THAT WE THINK THE
STAFF FOR PREPARING- VERY
THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS THAT ASKED
US ALL TO DIG DOWN A LITTLE BIT
MORE OKAY SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- FOR THAT. AN HOUR AGO HIS
GRIMACE AT CORTEZ SENATE
DEMOCRATS PUTTING WELL TO WORK
PLAN AND CHILD CARE PRIORITIES.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON SERRA CORTEZ
LA ELSE AFTER READ THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS BUDGET PLAN ON
HEALTHCARE ISSUE WHICH IS
OUTLINED IN YOUR AGENDA ON PAGE
SEVENTEEN THE SENATE DEMOCRATS
PLAN INCLUDES- ONE POINT ONE
BILLION OF ONGOING GENERAL FUND
TO INCREASE THE CHILD CARE AND
EARLY- EARLY EDUCATION
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR THE
NINETIETH PERCENTILE OF THE RMR
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE AND
PROVIDE A SET ASIDE FOR
INCREASING BENEFITS- IT ALSO
WEEKS FAMILY FEES FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS AND RETAIN
HOLD HARMLESS POLICIES TO PAY
PROVIDERS. BASED ON ENROLLMENT
FOR AN ADDITIONAL YEAR I PROVIDE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND- TO
FULLY FUND THE ANNUAL COST OF
FORTY SIX THOUSAND YOUR GENERAL
TELL KRISTOFF PROVIDED IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET.
PROVIDES A HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR EARLY LEARNING AND. CARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANT
PROGRAM. I HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION TIME CHEN FUNDFIRST
ROUND FOR SIX. INNINGS FOR THE
CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS PROGRAM.
AND PROVIDES A HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION PROGRAM TO INCREASE
THE AND SUPPORT INCLUSION OF
SHIP OF CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS AND PROGRAMS YOUR TRAINING
FACILITY RENOVATIONS WE COMMIT.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD EXPAND UPON
PROPOSALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT PROVIDES FUNDING.
FOR THIS PURPOSE FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SO THE
SENATE IS VERY HAPPY TO WE START
OFF WITH OUR SENIORS AND THEN-
AND THEN GO TO OUR TO OUR
YOUNGEST PEOPLE. TO BE BLE TO
REALLY AGAIN MAKE PEOPLE MAKE
CALIFORNIA'S WELLS WORK FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE- THREE
THANK YOU FOR READING FOR THOSE
FOR US AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
PUTTING THE SET PRIORITIES INTO
INTO EFFECT- AND WE DO HAVE
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT. ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE FROM VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS. AND I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO BE ALSO FROM THE L. A.
L. YES THANK YOU PROCEED WITH
THE L. A. L. SIMILAR TO THE
PRIOR ITEMS- THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
REQUEST WILL READ OFF THE LIST
OF STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS
INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA YOUR
ISSUE TWELVE. FIFTY FRESHENS
COME UP WOULD BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP- WITH THE APPROPRIATE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND GET BACK
TO THE SUB COMMITTEE STAFF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH SO TO KICK
IT OFF WE'LL START WITH THE
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. THE FIRST BEING
THE CHILDREN OF INCARCERATED
PARENTS TASK FORCE. AND THIS
PROPOSAL COMES FROM
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE BAY AREA
CHILDREN OF INCARCERATED PARENTS
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY WORKS.
GREASE AND CHILD POVERTY
CALIFORNIA AND SAN FRANCISCO
DISTRICT. ATTORNEY CASE OF- THE
- M. IS A REQUEST OF HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME AND BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
ESTABLISH THE TASK FORCE. ON
CHILDREN OF INCARCERATED PARENTS
AND CAREGIVERS UNDER THE CHILD
WELFARE COUNCIL THE TASK FORCE
WILL FOCUS ON MEETING THE NEEDS
OUR SYSTEM IMPACTED CHILDREN BY
SUBMITTING A REPORT TO THE CHILD
WELFARE COUNCIL. THE OFFICE OF
THE GOVERNOR CHIEF JUSTICE OF
CALIFORNIA THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO IDENTIFY
THE CHALLENGES OF SYSTEM
IMPACTED CHILDREN AND PROVIDE
POLICY IN FISCAL RECOMMENDATIONS
TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS. AND
SERVICE PRIORITIES OF THIS
POPULATION. THE NEXT I REQUEST
COMES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD NETWORK.
CRADLE TO CAREER COALITION
GRACE. S. AND CHILD POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA INSCRIBE TOGETHER. A
SPONSOR'S REQUEST NINETY TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA COURT NEEDED
NEIGHBORHOOD AND COMMUNITY
SERVICES GRANT PROGRAM. THE
PROGRAM WOULD GRANT AWARDS ON A
COMPETITIVE BASIS TO ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES THAT ARE PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOODS AND A COMMUNITY
BASED NETWORKS FOR REGIONAL
CRADLE TO CAREER NETWORK. AND
PROVIDE SERVICES THAT SUPPORT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES RUBBLE.
FOR BIRTH THROUGH COLLEGE AND
CAREER. THE NEXT PROPOSAL COMES
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC GUARDIANS
AND PUBLIC CONSERVATORS CBH D.
H. C. W. D. EIGHT C. SACK AND
EIGHT OTHER ORGANIZATIONS. THE
COALITION OF TWELVE
ORGANIZATIONS- ARE REQUESTING
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF WO HUNDRED MILLION
ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT PUBLIC
GUARDIANS AND PUBLIC
CONSERVATORS TO PROTECT CLIENT
ASSETS AND FACILITATE DECISION
MAKING TO IMPROVE THE WELLBEING
OF CLIENTS FOR NOT EVEN TO CARE
FOR THEMSELVES. RESPOND QUICKLY
TO EMERGENCY SITUATIONS IN TIME
TO PROTECT ASSETS AND HELP
CLIENTS STABILIZE PREVENTING THE
LOSS OF THEIR HOMES AND ENSURING
THEIR ASSET SUPPORT THEIR CARE.
IMPROVE THE FREQUENCY OF CLIENT
VISITS TO HELP CLIENTS MAINTAIN
STABILITY IN THEIR PLACEMENTS
AND TREATMENT AND TO AVOID
HOMELESSNESS AND ENHANCE ABILITY
TO PARTICIPATE AND PROSECUTION
OF ELDER FINANCIAL CRIMES CAN
PARTICIPATE AND FINANCIAL ABUSE
SPECIALIST TEAMS TO ENSURE
RESTITUTION. OWED BY CONVICTED
PERPETRATORS OF FINANCIAL ABUSE
IS PAID ENSURE PROTECTION OF THE
STATE'S FROM ADDITIONAL LOSSES
DUE TO FINANCIAL ABUSE- AND TO
INFLUENCE. FOR THE NEXT COUPLE
ARE WITH TO DEPART OF HEALTH
CARE ACT IT FOR. ON THE SPONSORS
ARE AN ESSAY N. EIGHT S. W.
CALIFORNIA C. WTA SEIU
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF DEANS AND
DIRECTORS OF SOCIAL WORK. THESE
ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURES FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION AVAILABLE
UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY SIX TO ESTABLISH A GRANT
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT THE
FOLLOWING. THIRTY MILLION FOR
GRANTS TO SCHOOLS OF SOCIAL WORK
TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF NSW
STUDENTS AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS OF
SOCIAL WORK. FIFTEEN MILLION PER
YEAR TO INCREASE SUPPORT TO
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND COUNTY
AGENCIES OFFERING FIELD
INTERNSHIPS AND THIRTEEN MILLION
PER YEAR FOR EDUCATIONAL
STIPENDS TO MSW STUDENTS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
THE REQUESTED CLUES A FOLLOW UP
STUDY FOR THE SB TWENTY THIRTY
CHILD WELFARE WORKLOAD STUDY
GIVEN SIGNIFICANT NEW MANDATES
ENACTED IN RECENT YEARS WHAT
THEY CALL ONE MILLION. THE NEXT
PROPOSAL COMES FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS. WHICH WOULD BY-
REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES FORTY TWO MILLION
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO
SUPPORT DATA COLLECTION REPORT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
SERVICE AN ANALYSIS ABOUT UA
ATION AND SHOWCASE PILOT
PROJECTS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
REFERENCE AS THEY MAKE POLICY
DECISIONS GOING FORWARD
REGARDING THE IMPACT OF
BROADBAND ACCESS EXPECTS. ON
HEALTHCARE. THE NEXT TO GO TO
PROPOSALS FALL UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THE PROPOSAL ON THIS
PROPOSAL COMES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA OKTAN UP UP TO METRIC
ASSOCIATION- WHICH REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY EIGHT MILLION ANNUALLY
TO MODERNIZE THE MEDIC COW
REIMBURSEMENT RATES PROVIDED
FOR- OPTOMETRIC SERVICES. THE
NEXT PROPOSAL COMES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION ASSOCIATION.
WHICH REQUEST EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION FIVE POINT SIX WHICH
CONSIST OF FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND FIVE
POINT ONE MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS
ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT INCREASED
PAYMENTS FOR NON EMERGENCY
TRANSPORTATION. PROVIDERS IN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM PROVIDING
SERVICES IN BOTH THE FEE FOR
SERVICE AND MANAGED CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS. THE NEXT
PROPOSAL COMES FROM THE MENTAL
HEALTH ASSOCIATION OF SAN
FRANCISCO WHICH REQUEST
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FIND OF
NINE POINT ONE MILLION IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. AND TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR ELEVEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX AND SIX
POINT EIGHT MILLION TWENTY
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN TO
SUPPORT INCREASING THE CAPACITY
OF SERVICES OF THE CALIFORNIA
PIER WILL RISE WARM LINE.
INCLUDING INTEGRATION WITH NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT SERVICES
CONDUCTING ANTI STIGMA OUTREACH
AND MARKETING TO PROVIDERS
PARTNERS LOCAL ONE RULE AND BY
POX COMMUNITIES TO MEET THE
GROWING NEEDS ESTABLISHING A
WARM LINE COALITION TASKED WITH
DEVELOPING BEST PRACTICE
TRAININGS. AND PROVIDING GRANTS
TO SUPPORT DEVELOPMENT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR APPEAR WARM
LINE NETWORK COMPLEMENTING THE
NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT AND
LIFELINE NETWORK I WILL NOW PASS
IT ON TO MY COLLEAGUE ANGELA
SHORT FOR- AND THE FOLLOWING.
NEXT PROPOSALS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU THE ACTUAL SHOW
WITH L. A. O. AS MY COLLEAGUE NO
I'LL BE READING THAT I SEVERAL
HOLES HOLES- BEGINNING.
MEANWHILE CAN CAP IN FUNDING. WE
WILL COUNTY THE CHECK- COUNTY OF
ORANGE. REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TEN
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE TO EXPAND PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE BE WELL
CAMPUS IN ORANGE COUNTY TO
ACCOMMODATE MORE RESIDENTS
SEEKING TREATMENTS. NEXT IS
VISION TO LEARN. VISION TO LEARN
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWO MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
TO SUPPORT VISION TO LEARN TO
BRING VISION SCREENING AND OTHER
VISION SERVICES TO STUDENTS IN
TITLE ONE SCHOOLS IN SACRAMENTO.
COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY AND THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. NEXT IS
RESTORATION OF AB NINETY SEVEN
REDUCTION FOR CLINICAL
LABORATORY SERVICES. CALIFORNIA
CLINICAL LABORATORY ASSOCIATION
REQUEST ANNUAL EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY TO RESTORED THE 10%
REDUCTION IN REIMBURSEMENT FOR
CLINICAL LABORATORY SERVICES IN
THE MEDICAL PROGRAMS IMPOSED BY
AB NINETY SEVEN- CHAPTER THREE
STATUTES OF TWENTY ELEVEN. THE
NEXT PROPOSAL IS ENHANCED
CLINICALLY INTEGRATED PROGRAM.
S. CI YOU REQUESTS EXPENDITURE
OF THIRTY OF ONE BILLION
INCLUDING FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND SIX HUNDRED
MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS ANNUALLY
TO SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING. ONE
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION WOULD
SUPPORT CLINICS IN THE FORM OF
AN ENHANCED ALTERNATIVE PAYMENTS
TO PAY FOR WAGES AND BENEFITS
FOR CLINIC WORKERS AND PROVIDERS
AND TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION BUT
SUPPORT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COOPERATION COMMITTEES TO TRAIN
YOUR WORKERS TEND UP SKILLED
CURRENT WORKERS. NEXT PROPOSAL
IS GROUND AMBULANCE FACE RATE
INCREASES MEDIC HOUSE. A
COALITION OF THE AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS AND LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
BETWEEN THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE
MILLION ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT AN
INCREASE IN A MINUTE CAL BASE
RATE REIMBURSEMENT. FOR GROUND
AMBULANCE. ONE HUNDRED. THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS. THAT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER LICENSURE
FUNDS. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES AND
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS REQUEST GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE OF THIRTY FOUR
MILLION ANNUALLY UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN TO%
BACKFILL EXPENDITURES FROM THE
RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT
LICENSURE FUNDS TO AVOID A FEE
INCREASE ON FACILITY LICENSE
PERMITS ANNUAL FEES. OTHER NEXT
PROPOSAL FALLS UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
WHICH IS LS WRAPAROUND GRANT
AUGMENTATION THE GOLDEN WEST
CHAPTER OF THE ALS ASSOCIATION
REQUESTS GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TWO
MILLION UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY SIX TO EXPAND
ACCESS AND SUPPORT FOR MULTI
DISCIPLINARY CLINICS AND TO
INCREASE PATIENT ASSISTANCE FUND
CAPACITY. THE FUNDING WOULD
SUPPORT DEVELOP YOU START CENTER
SO ONCE ONE IN THE BAY AND ONE
IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA. BY
THANKS SERVER WAS NOT A
REASONABLE PROXY TO A TREE
CENTER. THE ANNUAL CALL OF THE
CHAPTER CARE SO. AND COSTS FOR
CRITICALLY NEEDED DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AND
AUGMENTATIVE COMMUNICATION
EQUIPMENTS. AND THE NEXT
PROPOSAL- FALLS UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT. A COALITION OF
OVER FIFTY FARMWORKER
ORGANIZATIONS AND NGO PARTNERS
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK AND THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK REQUEST TWENTY
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME TO SUPPORT THE FARMWORKER
HOUSING COMPONENT. OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S LOW INCOME HOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM. AND WITH
THAT I WILL PASS IT ALONG TO MY
COLLEAGUE BRIAN ANDERSON TO
RECONNECT SEVERAL PROPOSALS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AFTERNOON
NEWS NEXT PROPOSALS REALLY TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. FIRST IS
CALLED SAFE JOBS AND HEALTHY
FAMILIES. IS SPONSORED BY THE
SAVE JOBS AND HEALTHY FAMILIES
CAN INTERNATIONAL CAMPAIGN FOR
RESPONSIBLE TECHNOLOGY. OTHER
SPONSORS BUT THIS REQUEST
FUNDING AND LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE
DDS ACCESS AND STORE RENTAL
OCCUPATION DATA. NEXT UP
PROPOSAL IS ENTITLED SB SIX
THIRTY NINE WORK GROUP SPONSORED
BY THE SB SIX THIRTY NINE
WORKROOM. THE DESCRIPTION OF
THIS SAYS RESPONSE REQUEST THREE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE MULTI YEAR PHASE OUT
OF THE FOURTEEN C. PROGRAM AND
ENSURE THE SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION
OF MORE THAN SIX THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS OUT OF THE FOURTEEN
C. PROGRAMS. THE NEXT PROPOSALS
ALL RELATED CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THEY INCLUDE SECURING SSI
SUPPORT FOR FOSTER YOUTH THIS IS
SPONSORED BY THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND THE YOUTH
LAWCENTER. OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND YOUTH
LAWCENTER REQUEST EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
TWO GENERAL FUND ON GOING TO
IMPROVE STATE AND COUNTY
CAPACITY. TO SECURE FEDERAL
SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY INCOME OR
SSI SUPPORTS FOR FOSTER YOUTH
WITH DISABILITIES. AND THIS
WOULD BE WITH A FOCUS ON
TRANSITIONING TO. THANKS
PROPOSALS ENTITLED UPDATES TO
THE LIFTING CHILDREN WHOSE
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY TASK
FORCE REPORT. IS SPONSORED BY
THE GRACE INSTITUTE AND CHILD
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA- SPONSORED
QUEST ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE TIME TO
UPDATE THE LISTING CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY ASK FOR
SUPPORT WITH NEW CENSUS DATA
INTO REFLECT THE INVESTMENTS
MADE SINCE THE PLAN WAS
PUBLISHED. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. THE NEXT PROPOSALS
ENTITLED CALIFORNIA EXTENDED
CASE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. IT IS
SPONSORED BY AFGHAN FOR A BETTER
TOMORROW COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS. CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS. H. A. S. HOME FOR
REFUGEES USA INTERNATIONAL
INSTITUTE IS A LEADING.
INTERNATIONAL RESCUE COMMITTEE
INTERFAITH REFUGEE AND
IMMIGRATION SERVICES OF THIS
COUPLE DIOCESE OF LOS ANGELES
AWAIS IS LEGAL SERVICES OPENING
DOORS INCORPORATED AND WE ARE
ALL IN THERE. THIS YOUR TOTAL
SEVENTY NINE POINT MILLION OVER
TWO YEARS TO ESTABLISH PROGRAM
TO EXPAND CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES FOR NUTRITIONAL NINE
MONTHS FOR A TOTAL OF UP TO ONE
YEAR. CLOSE PROGRAM WOULD BUILD
ON EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
CASE MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA COULD
BE EXPANDED TO MEET THE CURRENT
NEEDS. NEXT PROPOSALS ENTITLED
KINSHIP NAVIGATOR PROGRAM FOR
CALIFORNIA'S UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN. THIS SPONSORED BY THE
INSTITUTE FOR JUSTICE. RESPONSE
REQUESTED TOTAL TWENTY FIVE
POINT NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND
TO BE SPENT OVER THREE YEARS TO
ESTABLISH A PILOT PROGRAM THAT
WOULD PROVIDE KINSHIP NAVIGATORS
TO ASSIST FELLOW COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE
SPONSORSHIP PROCESS. NEXUS
ENTITLED. INCREASING PUBLIC
BENEFITS UTILIZATION. IS
SPONSORED BY THE SYSTEM. THE
SPONSOR REQUEST SIX MILLION ONE
TIME TO IMPLEMENT A THREE YEAR
PILOT IN ALAMEDA COUNTY DESIGNED
TO IMPROVE AWARENESS OF PUBLIC
BENEFITS AND INCREASED
BENEFITING UTILIZATION. PILOT
WOULD ALLOW THE STATE TO LEARN
HEALTH MINISTER ACTIVATING
SUPPORT AND LEVERAGE THE
COORDINATES OF THE SOCIAL CARE
PROVIDERS AND TECH ENABLED
EFFORTS TO INCREASE PUBLIC
BENEFITS UTILIZATION AT SCALE
PRIMARILY THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND STUDY OF THE
SYSTEM. THAT I WILL PASS IT
ALONG TO MY COLLEAGUES OR
QUESTIONS. THANK CAN RECORD.
WELCOME BACK. YOUR RECORD HAS
LEN SO THE TITLED STABLE AN
ONGOING MANY FREEDOM AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE SERVICES AND
PROGRAMMING ON THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VALEUR U. S. ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NETWORKS I'M REQUEST
EIGHTEEN MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONGOING JUST SUPPORT NONVIOLENCE
PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE SEEKING
SUPPORT IN HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS
WITH PROGRAMS TAILORED FOR MEN
THE L. G. B. T. Q. I A COMMUNITY
AND CULTURALLY ROOTED PROGRAM
THE FUNDING TO BE USED I
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE AND
CULTURALLY SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
INTEGRATE PILOT PROGRAMS. TO
ENCOURAGE CAPACITY. THE PROPOSAL
. CALIFORNIA SUCCESS OPPORTUNITY
AN ACADEMIC RESILIENCE
GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT PROGRAM.
THE ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION AND YOUNG. INVINCIBLES
REQUEST EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME BUNCH
CREATE A GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE MONTHLY
PAYMENTS OF A THOUSAND DOLLARS
UP TO. FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
EXPERIENCE- UP TO FIFTEEN
THOUSAND GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FOR FIVE MONTHS.
THE PROGRAM WILL SUPPORT
STUDENTS AS THEY GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL AND EITHER PURSUE.
PROSEC EDUCATION OR EMPLOYMENT.
AMERICANS THE CARE GIVER FUNDING
CONTINUITY THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND CHILDREN
NOW REQUEST ELEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FEDERAL FUNDS
AREN'T GOING FUNDING- TO
MINIMALLY EXTEND THE CURRENT
STATUTORY LANGUAGE RELATED TO
EMERGENCY CARE GIVER FUNDING
FROM NINETY TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS AND THEN IT'S MORE
CONSISTENT BILLING OF TIME
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL IS
ACTUALLY TAKING. THE DALLAS
REMOVING ANY INTENTIONAL BURDEN
ON CAREGIVERS WHO DID NOT
COMPLETE RSA IN NINETY DAYS DUE
TO THE CIRCUMSTANCES OUTSIDE THE
CONTROL AND MAKING THEM RELIANT
ON THE STATE MAKING A
DETERMINATION THAT THE RP
PROCESS CANNOT BE COMPLETED
WITHIN NINETY DAYS DUE TO THE-
DID THE CIRCUMSTANCES OUTSIDE OF
THE CASE CONTROL THIS PROPOSAL
MAKES EMERGENCY CARE GIVER
PAYMENTS ELIGIBLE FOR THE
FEDERAL AND STATE SHARE PAYMENT
UNTIL APPROVAL OR DENIAL OF THE
RESOURCE. APPLICATION OR FOR UP
TO A HUNDRED TWENTY. DAYS
WHICHEVER COMES FIRST. I'M BOB
AND TRAV REMEMBER RATE UPDATE
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN RIGHTS
AND CHILDREN NOW WORKS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHEN FUND ONE TIME TO
THIS. THE SOCIAL SERVICES
STAKEHOLDER- CONSULTATION UPDATE
THE RATE DETERMINATION
PROCEDURES AND INCREASES
EDUCATION TRAVEL REIMBURSEMENT
RATE PROVIDED TO OFFSET SOME OF
THE COST FOR CARE GIVERS TO
TRANSPORT CHILDREN. IN FOSTER
CARE TO THE SCHOOL OF ORIGIN AND
TO ESTABLISH A REGULAR SCHEDULE
TO CONSULT WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
UPDATE THE RATE REFLECT CURRENT
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS RELATED TO
TRANSPORTATION COSTS. MENTAL
HEALTH AND CARE COORDINATION
SERVICES FOR PERSONS DIAGNOSED
WITH SICKLE CELL DISEASE-
RELATED THE FUNDING OR- THEY
CAME BACK- THAT THEY CAN'T KATE
HI AND WELLNESS CENTER REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION ANNUALLY UNTIL- JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY SIX TO
SUPPORT THE WELLNESS CENTER TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO HEALTH SERVICES
SOCIAL SERVICES AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
SUFFERING FROM SICKLE CELL
DISEASE. WHEN YOU REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AND FREEDOM FUND. ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE BLACK WOMEN
FOR WELLNESS ACTION PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE FOR
QUESTIONS OFTEN EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FOR FIFTEEN MILLION
AVAILABLE UNTIL DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. WHOSE JOB WAS TO
CALIFORNIA REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
AND FREEDOM FUND WHICH WOULD
DISMANTLE STORK AND STANDING
SAID- SYSTEMIC REPRODUCTIVE AND
SEXUAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
THROUGH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION PROVISION OF
MEDICALLY ACCURATE CULTURALLY.
AGREEMENT EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
AS WELL AS DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES THAT ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES OF REPRODUCTIVE
OPPRESSION. FUNGAL OF L. A.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
REQUEST GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION AVAILABLE OVER THREE
YEARS TO SUPPORT. IN THE NATION
FOR THE LAST COUNTY UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
CAMPUS WHICH WOULD CREATE A
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLBEING
ABILITY SHE SUPPORT INTEGRATED
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESSES AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. THANK
YOU MUCH TO ALL THE THAT
DEPARTMENT FINE ERIDU YET HELLO
READERS. AND WE THINK THE
STAKEHOLDERS FOR SUBMITTING
THEIR IDEAS- AND THEIR
PROPOSALS. AND WE NOW WILL BE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENTS SO
FIRST WILL TURN TO THE HEARING
ROOM. AND KNOW IF ANYBODY HAS
ANY COMMENT MADE TO PLEASE LINE
UP. AND GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
AROUND HAGER- A RECORDING
DIFFERENT HATS THE FIRST HAD TO
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE HERE TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
GUARDIANSHIP- IN FUNDING- THE
SECOND IS I'M REPRESENTING MINDO
SEE WHICH IS THE OVER UMBRELLA
ORGANIZATION FOR THE BE WELL
FOLKS WHO HAVE PARTNERED WITH
ORANGE COUNTY- AND BEING THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE SUPPOSED. ELEMENT
THAT'S CURRENTLY BEFORE. MUCH
EXPRESSION PLEASE. HELLO YET ANY
MONEY ON ALSO PROVIDING TWO
QUICK COMMENTS FIRST ON BEHALF
OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS EXPRESSING SUPPORT
FOR THE PROPOSAL BILL OF BUILD
CAPACITY FOR MASTERS OF SOCIAL
WORK PROGRAMS AND SECONDLY ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE COUPLE'S STORY
GUARANTEED IN HIGHLAND GRAHAM
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK FIRST PLEASE. YEAH A
STATUS. OF CAN MINISTRY WAS
PUBLIC CONSERVATIVE PUBLIC
GUARDIANS- IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE STATE
SUPPORT. FOR THOSE- SERVICES- TO
HELP AUGMENT WHICH COUNTIES ARE
ALREADY PROVIDING APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT AND WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ASSEMBLY WILL
FOLLOW SUIT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MARKET SEE JOHN BEHALF OF
THE L. A. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HOUSE FOR THE RESORT
VILLAGE PROJECT AT THE LHC USC
MEDICAL CENTER CAMPUS. IN TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
SOMEONE TIME STATE GENERAL FUND
TO PROVIDE A RANGE OF CRITICAL
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. AS A
GROWING NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
CONTINUES TO OUTPACE RESOURCES
FOR CRITICAL SERVICES AT ALL
LEVELS OF CARE. LOS ANGELES
COUNTY HAS ABILITY REDUCE
INITIATIVE AT THE LEC USC
MEDICAL CAMPUS TO CREATE A
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLBEING
VILLAGE TO SUPPORT INTEGRATED
SERVICES FOR ONE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. THESE
FUNDS WOULD GO TOWARDS THE REAR
PERCENT OF EXISTING WARDS L. A.
C. U. S. D. I'D PSYCHIATRIC
INPATIENT BEDS DALTON
ADOLESCENCE. IN A TO THESE TO GO
TOWARDS DEVELOPMENT OF RECOVERY
IN RESPITE CENTRE. MENTAL
PATIENT CENTER. AND A SECURE. IN
FACILITY. I'M HAPPY TO SHARE
THAT THIS BUDGET REQUEST IS A
PRIORITY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
WHICH ALLEGED CAUCUS. AND A PART
OF HELPING. PARTNER THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH THANKS. HELLO MY NAME
IS NOW I MEAN OUR I'M HERE FOR
THE REIMBURSEMENT FOR THEM- I
HAVE A IN UNIPER. FOR LOCALS
TWENTY IN SOUTH AND- I'VE BEEN
WORKING THERE FOR ABOUT FOUR
YEARS I'M ALSO A MOTHER FOR IN A
WINDOW. I MY AGE I CAN HEAR TENS
BUT SAY THE A STRUGGLE TO REST
OF S. TO AN HOUR. I WAS ACTUALLY
WORKING TO BEST OPTION I PLAYED.
SHUT DOWN FROM ONE THAN. I HAVE
SOLD ITEMS AND- CASE JUST. ME IN
THE MAIL.
PARAMEDICS ARE ON SCENE WITH
FIRE AND POLICE SAVING LIVES
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WORRY IF
THEY- CAN PAY RENT BUY FOOD OR
PAY THEIR BILL. WE SHOULDN'T
NEED TO WORK MULTIPLE JOBS IN
ORDER TO DO WHAT WE LOVE AND IS
NEEDED TO SAVE LIVES. BE AN EMS-
MEANS WE WORK HOLIDAYS WEEKENDS
OVERTIME AND MANDATORY HOLDOVERS
DUE TO THE IMPORTANCE OF THE JOB
AND TO STAFF TOWARD SHORTAGE.
YOU DO THIS BECAUSE IT IS A COPY
OF THOSE IN NEED I SEE SIGNS FOR
RETAIL FAST FOOD THAT I CAN MAKE
MORE MONEY WORKING BUT I CAN'T I
LOVE MY JOB. I MUST RECORDS IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE. THEIR WEIGHT.
A LIVABLE WAGE I ASKED THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT FIRST
RESPONDER LIKE MY A THANK THE
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATE.
THAT WE CAN SEE JUST I WANT CAN
YOU TO WORK AND THAT I LOVE.
ALSO MY- FOR MY- PLEASE HELP ME
TO BALANCE OR WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK IN THE INDUSTRY WE LOVE
THANK YOU THINK IT'S TIME THANKS
FOR SOME FISH. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM MY NAME IS FULLY BETTER.
I'M A UNION PRESIDENT FOR LOCAL
SIXTY OF THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION EMTS AND PARAMEDICS
ARE REPRESENT OVER THREE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES IN L. A. COUNTY WHO
RUN NINE ONE ONE TRANSPORTS
PATIENTS. I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE
PERFECT FIT VERY FEW PROFESSIONS
THAT STRANGER LIKE YOURSELF
WOULD LET ME INTO YOUR HOME AND
INTO YOUR LIFE WHEN YOU NEED ME.
A IT'S DIFFICULT TO DO THAT
NOWADAYS SENATE DON'T. SIX ARDOR
. SO LOOK BRAND TREES A LOT OF
MY COVER OF LEFT ANY OF JOB DUE
TO FIND REASONS. THE EMS SYSTEMS
THAT CRISIS NOW AND PART OF
THAT. SOLUTION IS INCREASING THE
TRANSPORTATION RATES IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE DO WHEN WE
HAVE A CRITICAL PATIENTS
SOMETIMES ALL IT IS JUST
STOPPING THE BLEEDING. AND
TAKING THAT STEP PRIEST AND-
IT'S ONE OF EVERYTHING BUT I'LL
STOP THE BLEEDING FOR US WERE
OFTEN LOOKED UPON TO. YES
EMERGENCIES ARE WE SHALL BE WE
HAVE THE ANSWERS TO FIX THE
PROBLEM. FROM HERE ASKING THE
STATE TO BE THAT FOR US SHOWS
THAT THE EMERGENCY CAN BE OVER
SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES AND FROM THE SERVER
. THANK YOU. VERY MUCH. THE
PERSON PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN OF MY NAME'S JAMES
PEARSON ON THE PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION I'M ALSO
PRESIDENT OF A FAMILY OWNED
OPERATED BUSINESS MY
GRANDPARENTS ARE TRYING AGAIN A
MEDIC ON SERVICE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ALSO AS CAN BEEN
THIS INDUSTRY FOR OUR TWENTY
THREE YEARS. OUR NAY HIS URINE
BE- MERCERS WALTON AND- DID YOU
TAKE A OF STAGNATION WE CAN'T
WAIT AROUND ANY LONGER FOR AN
INCREASE IN MEDICARE. OUR
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT. IS
ACTUALLY IT WAS HIGHER IN
NINETEEN NINETY SENATORS TODAY.
AS WE STAND HERE TODAY WE GET
PAID A HUNDRED ELEVEN DOLLARS
PER TRANSPORT- THAT'S REGARDLESS
OF TIME REQUIREMENT MANPOWER-
THAT WE DEDICATE TO A CALL. I
THINK YOU'D BE HARD PRESSED TO
FIND ANY OF OUR COSTS. THAT HAVE
NOT INCREASING THAT TWO DECADES
AS WELL. DURING OUR PANDEMIC YOU
SAW THE CALIBER OF OUR EMPLOYEES
ARE THE WORKERS WHO WORK IN OUR
PROFESSION PUT ASIDE THEIR OWN
WELL BEING IN OUR WELL BEINGS
AND CONTINUE TO ANSWER CALLS FOR
SERVICE. IN THEIR OWN SAFETY
THESE ARE WORKERS OR LOSING
EVERY DAY. AS A AS A PROFESSION
THE ONES WILLING TO SERVE OTHERS
IN AN EMERGENCY THE ONES WHO
SAVE LIVES AND WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO LOSE ANYMORE. ALL FOR A RACE
FORTY SIX OUT OF FIFTY STATES A
MEDICAL TRANSPORT REIMBURSEMENT
AND WE SERVE THE LARGEST MEDICAL
POPULATION. THE NEW YORK PAYS
MORE FLORIDA PAYS DOUBLE TEXAS
PAYS NEARLY TRIPLE ARIZONA PAYS
ONLY SEVEN TIMES MORE THAN WE
GET PAID. CALIFORNIA WANTS US TO
SERVE THE MOST VULNERABLE
PATIENTS HOWEVER. WERE NOW
BECOMING THE MOST HORRIBLE
WORKFORCE. WE'RE NOT REALLY
WE'RE NOT REALLY ON THE PROMISED
SO WE HAD TO SERVE OUR PATIENTS
AND OUR COMMUNITY WE'RE RUNNING
A WILLING TO SERVE BUT WE NEED
YOUR ASSISTANCE WE NEED TO
COMPENSATE OUR EMPLOYEES
PROPERLY- CAN WE NEED TO BE
COMPENSATED PROPERLY TO DO THAT.
IN THIS ROOM AND ON THE PHONE
REPRESENTATIVES OF A OF A ONCE
IN MY LIFETIME COALITION OF
LABOR. AN AMBULANCE SERVICES
SOLUTIONS FROM REPRESENTING
ENTIRE STATE CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE
NEEDS YEAH YOU AND I ALSO
ASSOCIATION EMTS AND PARAMEDICS-
ASKED ME. YOU KNOW IDEA MUST
WORKERS AND UNITED STEELWORKERS
THAMES ARE. REPRESENTING ABOUT
TWELVE THIRTEEN ABOUT TWELVE TO
THIRTEEN THOUSAND EMS WORKERS IN
OVER TWO MILLION TRANSPORTS.
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE UNIFIED IN OUR COSTS. ARE
COALITION. SORRY WE'VE BEEN
SOUNDING THE ALARM IN CALIFORNIA
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE JOINING
US YOUR HONOR COLLEAGUES IN
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE RECEIVE MORE
THAN THREE THOUSAND EMAILS
CALIFORNIANS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE ECHOING THIS CALL FOR
FERRETS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS PERSON PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR OF THE
SENATE HUMANNESS POLICY
ASSOCIATE FOR. GRAYSON CHAO
PARTY CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
SUPPORT. OF TWO FOR THE FRONT
PROPOSALS LISTED UNDER ISSUE
ELEVEN INITIAL TWELVE AND WE
REALLY JUST WANT TO THANK THE
SENATE FOR INCLUDING PROPOSALS
THAT STRENGTHEN. OUR CHILD CARE
WORKERS OR CHILD CARE SYSTEM- WE
ALSO WANT TO- SPECIFICALLY
THANK- YOU KNOW SENATE FOR ALSO
INCLUDING- THEIR REQUEST TO URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO FUND
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE TASK FORCE
FOR CHILDREN OF INCARCERATED
PARENTS. UNDER THE CHILD WELFARE
COUNCIL YOU KNOW PERSONALLY AS A
CHILD WHO GREW UP WITH
INCARCERATED PARENTS IS ONE THAT
IS VERY PERSONAL TO ME AND SO.
YOU KNOW- IN CALIFORNIA ALONG WE
HAVE A- HIGH HISTORY OF MASS
INCARCERATION IN OUR STATE. AND
IT'S THE SAME WE CAN'T TAKE AWAY
BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY ADDRESS IT-
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
PROPOSALS- WE ALSO URGE A ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FUNDING FOR
INVESTMENT AT THE LISTING
CHILDREN. AND FAMILIES OUT OF
TASK FORCE REPORT AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR INCLUDING THAT IN THE
AGENDA- IT'S BEEN A PROPOSAL OR
POVERTY PLAN THAT HAS BEEN VERY
VITAL. AND PROVEN TO BE.
EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF
COLLABORATION AND BRING
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER. CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF. PROGRAMS YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOU VERY MUCH THANK
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS CHRISTINE TRÊN
FROM GREECE AND CHILD POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA AND A MEMBER OF THE
CRADLE TO CAREER COLLISION WE'RE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA COURT IN NEIGHBORHOOD
AND COMMUNITY SERVICE GRANT
PROGRAM UNDER ISSUE TWELVE
BOTTLES AN AWFUL. CURRENTLY
THERE IS NO STATE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS THAT BUILD
COMMUNITY WIDE TYPE PLANS OF
INTEGRATED HEALTH ACADEMIC AND
COMMUNITY SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
FAMILIES AT EVERY STAGE OF LIFE
FROM BEFORE BIRTH THROUGH
COLLEGE AND FEAR OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS CRITICAL ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE A SYMBOL ON TERROR SPONSOR
ABILITY WORKING A PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC SECTOR PARTNERS IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. TO LEVY A PROPERTY WITH A
SUBSTANTIAL WORK HAS BEEN DONE
BY THESE ORGANIZATIONS WE MUST
NOT LOSE ASSESSABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S BEEN BUILT
IN THE STATE AS FEDERAL SEED
MONEY SUNSETS THIS YEAR FOR
CERTAIN ORGANIZATIONS. AND OTHER
ORGANISED OPERATE LIMIT CAPACITY
THE CALIFORNIA ACCORDING
NEIGHBORHOOD AND COMMUNITY
SERVICE GRANT PROGRAM WILL HELP
THIS AND EXPAND THE CRADLE TO
CAREER APPROACH FOR A COUPLE
RECOVERY AND FUTURE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MEXICO
EXPERTS PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MANY MISSILES DOESN'T ARE. HIS
PCS I WERE MEMBERS OF THE
CRADLE- THE COMPANY CREDITS A
PRE COLLISION. AND WE HEAR IN
SUPPORT OF- THE IT TAKES A
VILLAGE ACT. IN SUPPORT OF- THE
CRITICAL. INITIATIVES WE
IMPLEMENT THE PROMISE NAY BUT
CRADLE TO CAREER MODELING THE
COMMUNITIES OF CHULA VISTA AND
SAN DIEGO. AND SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CRADLE TO
CAREER- WE JUST HAS BEEN A MAJOR
TRANSFORMATION IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITY. DEGREE FOR EVERY
CHILD AND YOUTH THAT ARE CLOSED
PROMISING. AND CRITICALLY
MODELS. WITH THE 90% OF OUR
CHILDREN THAT ARE- GOING CAN TO
READY- ALL OF OUR KIDS GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND GOING TO
COLLEGE. AND IN THE TIME OF
GREATEST NEED YOU KNOW AND AT
THE PEAK OF THE PANDEMIC-
PROMISING BUT WAS THERE AND
THESE CRITICALLY MODELS WHERE
THEIR- SUPPORT- YOU KNOW
VACCINATION CONTACT TRACING FOOD
SECURITY AND HOUSING. BUT I
REALLY THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT FROM THE THESE
INITIATIVES IS THAT IT DOES THAT
CULTURAL SHIFT- THAT IT'S- IT
DID. YOU SHOWS THAT YOU KNOW I
THE COMP WHEN WE BRING ALL THESE
INITIATIVES IN THE STRATEGIES
TOGETHER. MAKES A- MAJOR IMPACT
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. UP IN ORDER
TO KEEP THAT GOING YOU KNOW WE
NEED- WE SEE THIS BILL AS A KEY
COMPONENT TO. KEEP MOMENTUM
GOING. AND ALIGNING THE
STRATEGIES TOGETHER SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE
COMMUNITY. I THINK IT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
A FRAME OF REFERENCE. I WITH THE
MISSION PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD AND%
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA. COORDINATOR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND COMMUNITY
SERVICES GRANT PROGRAM UNDER
ISSUE TWELVE. THIS PROGRAM WILL
FUND IN EQUITY. FOCUS
COORDINATOR APPROACH AND
COMMUNITY BASED INFRASTRUCTURE.
HAS PROVIDED CRADLE TO CAREER
SERVICES. AND FOR THE LAST TEN
YEARS AS A TO SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES FOR LOW INCOME
CHILDREN. AND FAMILIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A PROVEN
PERFECT PLACE BASED COLLECTIVE
IMPACT MODEL. THAT WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN RESPONDING TO
THE ECONOMIC DISPARITIES. APPLE
FIVE BY THE PANDEMIC. ANY
CONTINUES TO PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE IN THE RECOVERY OF OUR MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES. HI URGE
THE SENATE COMMITTEE TO INVEST
IN THIS PROGRAM IN ORDER TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE THIS COMMUNITY
BASED WRAPAROUND GOOD GOVERNMENT
MODEL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY SEEING NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MONTEREY- ARE YOU THERE. I AM
HERE OKAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WHAT'S GOING ON GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MOTOR. ALL LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE TEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. YOU'RE USING
A SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
YOUR HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS AND ONCE AGAIN THAT IS
ONE THING ZERO. AND IT LOOKS
LIKE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ABOUT YOU
. RIGHT IN THE QUEUE OKAY START
WHERE IS. LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HI BOB
AND I HAVE BEEN ARRESTED IN THE
BOYLE HEIGHTS FOR TWENTY ONE
YEAR I LIVED DOWN THE STREET
FROM L. A. C. USC MEDICAL CENTER
AND I AM CALLING. FOR POLICE
REQUEST TO ALLOCATE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OF STATE
FUNDING THROUGH LA SEE USC
RESTORED AFTER A COLLECTION OF
MY FAMILY AND I SUPPORT THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE NUMBER
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. HEATHER HAYES AND I'M
HERE AT THE LOS ANGELES
RESIDENTS CONCERNED STAKEHOLDER
WHICH REALLY COMMITTED TO HEALTH
EQUITY HEARING FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS SPEAKING OF
TRONG SUPPORT AT THE REQUEST FOR
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND FOR THE
LED YOU AT THE RESORT OF
CARRABELLE. YOU LOOK AROUND OUR
COMMUNITY SEE ACROSS AMPLE WITH
PETE SUFFERING FROM MENTAL
HEALTH. ISSUES AND OTHER OF THE
CONSEQUENCES LEADING TO
HOMELESSNESS. IT CONDITIONS LEFT
UNTREATED ARCTIC FOR WHAT WE SEE
ON OUR STREETS AND IN OUR PRISON
AND JAIL CELLS EVERY. ITALIAN
COURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER THE FUNDING REQUEST
THAT WE CAN STOP THAT THE STOP
THE SPREAD OF HOMELESSNESS. AND
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF
MENTAL ILLNESS IS THAT THIS YEAR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS PERSON. BY NUMBER TWENTY
BECAUSE I HAD. AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR NICOLE BORNEMANN ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT OF A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS
FOR INVESTMENT. BARCLAYS SCREEN
OVERHEAD IN THE FACILITY AND
ALIVE. DURING EXERCISE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH WILL HELP BRING TO
THE ISSUES AS THEY ADJUST IN THE
TRANSITION TO ADULTHOOD
ADDITIONALLY PARTNERSHIP THE
COURTS THE PROPOSAL TO UPDATE
THE MISSING CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES OUT OF PROPERTY TASK.
AND WHAT BENEFITS UTILIZATION
FINALLY BOTH THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SAMPOERNA DINO
COUNTY COURT THE KINSHIP
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM FOR
CALIFORNIANS. AND ACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN. NAVIGATION AS PART OF
A GROWING BODY OF EVIDENCE
INDICATING THAT STRATEGIES TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES CAN IMPROVE
FILE PHOTO AND THE LONG TERM THE
LADY OF PLACEMENT WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND BEFORE WE GO TO THE
NEXT CALLER I'M GONNA STOP YOU
MODERATOR WE HAVE SOMEBODY BACK
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM OVER TO
TAKE A- BUT CALM- POLICY ON HOW.
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SATISFY- THIS IS
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THAT
ENHANCE THE HANDS CLINICALLY
INTEGRATED GRAHAM AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE HEARING
IT TODAY- IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE LIFTING UP OUR PRIMARY
CARE WORKFORCE TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THE GROWING MEDICARE
POPULATION AND- WOULD URGE THE
COMMITTEE AND- BUDGET COMMITTEE
TO INCLUDE IN THE FINAL BUDGET
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY. OPERATOR WERE BACK TO
YOU. ALL RIGHT ONE NINE ZERO OUR
- COMMENT AND WE WILL GO. WHY
NUMBER NINETY EIGHT IF I HAD. HI
I'M DARBY KERN AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF A COUPLE OF
ORGANIZATION. ON ISSUE NUMBER
ONE I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
MEALS ON WHEELS CALIFORNIA. IF
THE REINVESTMENT OF THE OLDER
CALIFORNIA'S. AND SUPPORT THE
FOR A BUDGET REQUEST I ISSUE
SEVEN MEDIAN AGE CALIFORNIA IS
THE LARGEST AND ONLY ASSOCIATION
AND STAKEHOLDER ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON NONPROFIT SECTOR
PRIVATE HEALTHY. CARE AND
SERVICES TO OLDER ADULTS. WE
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
INVESTMENT ON EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND BELIEVE OUR
EFFORTS ON THAT TO CREATE A
MUTUAL AID PLAN FOR SENIOR
HOUSING AND CARE FACILITIES. IS
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THIS
WORK AND FINALLY FOR THE FIRST
FIVE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORT THAT THAT. CHILDHOOD
PRESS. YEAH THANK YOU VERY NEXT
COLOR. WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER
NINETY THREE TWENTY FOUR HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ACT MENTIRA
BRANDY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES WHERE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE RESIDENTIAL AND
OUTPATIENT LICENSURE BACK FELL
UNDER THAT DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ON ISSUE TWELVE.
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING LICENSED
AND CERTIFIED A FEW KEY
TREATMENT PROGRAM IN CRITICAL
CRAFT ARE DEAD AND THE NEED FOR
SERVICES HAS GROWN DURING
COOKING NINETEEN ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL BE OVER THE LIFE
INSURER- YOU'D GO UP BY FORTY
FIVE PERCENT. BUT GOING BACK TO
MAKE A LACK OF TREATMENT PROGRAM
INCREASED AUTHORITY STRUGGLING
PROGRAM IMPORTANT ADDITIONAL.
PROGRAMS FROM COMING INTO THE-
YOUR BEST BENEFITS OF THE FACT
HELP PREVENT THE FEET. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
PLEASE. WE HAVE ONE- YOUR LONG
IS OPEN TWENTY FOUR HAD. I
REMEMBERREALLY ABLE TO HAPPEN
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS UNITED A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN YEAH YOU
EIGHTY W. WE APPRECIATE THE
HEARING TODAY AND RECOGNIZING
THE NEED FOR MORE FUNDING TO
FIGHT AND IF THE FAMILY
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AT THE
BUDGET BY THE SENATE BLUEPRINT.
THE REQUESTED FIVE JIM MILLIONS
ONLY A HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
AND HELPED A RETIREMENT BENEFITS
PAID TIME OFF IS THE CORE OUR
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATION IT BUT BETTER
CRUCIAL TO IMPROVE QUALITY FOR
AT THE TOP YOU'RE WORKFORCE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH MICHAEL PLEASE. MY
NAME ONE FOUR PAGE BOOK NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND SHARED BRING
A FOUR K. FROM THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN RIGHT BEGIN THE
FOURTEENTH. SITE SUPPORT FOR
FOSTER YOUTH PROPOSAL ISSUE
TWELVE ON PAGE TWENTY FIVE THE
FEDERAL AND I PROGRAM PROVIDES
NOT ONLY MONTHLY CASH ASSISTANCE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE IT ALSO
SUPPORTED WORKING HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES TO INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES WE CANNOT WORK
YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE
FACILITIES FREQUENTLY NEED CARE
ABOUT THE VALUABLE AND
POTENTIALLY LIKE WHAT. IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT. TO GET THE PROCESS
THE DALLAS YOU KNOW NINETEEN
ELIGIBLE. JANUARY BUT INVEST
ASSETS FOR FOSTER YOUTH
REQUIRING COUNTIES TO APPEAL TO
NIGHT AT THE APPLICATION AND I
BUDGET PROPOSAL IN THE STREET
AND CONTINUOUS COURT AGREED THAT
THIS REPORT FOR CAL HEALTH YOU
BURKE. WARNING MINISTRY TO.
THEIR FIRST APPEAL DENIED MUCH
LARGER OF AB- FOR A THE BY A
THAT THEY- THE OFFERING TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ACT AT THE GOOD
FOR YOU CAN. ERIC WE APPRECIATE
CONSIDERATION AND THAT'S- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE YOU.
OVERLYING NUMBER. ONE FIVE.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
TERRIBLE AND I'M REPRESENTING-
THE SB SIX THIRTY NINE WORK
GROUP- AND I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE WORKERS THREE
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT THE MULTI
YEAR PHASE OUT OF THE PARKING
FEE PROGRAM. BUT BEFORE GOING
BACK TO HIGHLIGHT COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT PILOT
PROJECT WHICH IS REALLY AN
INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO PROMOTING
EQUITY ACCESS AND INDEPENDENCE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES TRANSFERRING OUT OF
THE FOURTEENTH THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. WHAT A
LINE NUMBER ONE FOR YOU PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JEANNIE
FISHER WITH THE BRIGHT FUTURES
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIP A CRADLE
TO CAREER PARTNERSHIPS. GOING TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COORDINATED
NEIGHBORHOOD AND COMMUNITY
SERVICES GRANT PROGRAM UNDER
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BY NUMBER FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- HELLO TERRORISM
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS ON BOARD
SCRUTINIZED PRESIDENT. SPAMMER
STANDARDS AND MEMBER OF THE
FUNDS FIRST RESPONDERS COALITION
AND IN SUPPORT OF- AMBULANCE
MEDICAL COMPENSATION CREEK. BUT
I WOULD PROBABLY SERVE ALL OF
LOS ANGELES I'M WORKING ON
STANISLAUS COUNTY IS THE LAST TO
BEING IN THE CHAIRS DISTRICT AND
pWINDOW. FOR YOU INTO HOW MUCH
NOR CALIBRATION CHALLENGES. AND
SUGGEST THAT THIS IS INDICATIVE
OF ALL OF THE COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA. SO AMHERST AMBULANCE
LAUNCHED OPERATIONS IN SAN
JOAQUIN AND STANISLAUS COUNTIES
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THERE WERE NOT ENOUGH
PROVIDERS IN THE AREA AND WE
FELT WE NEEDED AND WELCOMED. SO
WE INVEST. ON BOTH THE
AMBULANCES AND HIRE THE EMPTIES
AND MADE A COMMITMENT. AND
BECAME PAINFULLY CLEAR VERY
QUICKLY. WHAT THERE HAS BEEN
VERY FEW PROVIDERS IN THIS
CONTEXT THE NUMBERS SIMPLY DON'T
ADD UP BECAUSE OF THE POSSIBLE
MEDICAL COMPENSATION. CURRENTLY
TRANSPORTED WITH TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MEDICAL PATIENTS A MONTH
IN SAN JOAQUIN AND STANISLAUS
COUNTY. WE MADE A COMMITMENT TO
THE HOSPITAL'S IN THOSE COUNTIES
AND THEY HAVE LEARNED TO RELY
ENOUGH BUT WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF
OUR ALLOCATED FUNDS. IF YOU'RE
COMMITTEE DOESN'T ACT HOW SHOULD
WE CONTINUE TO STAY IN BUSINESS
BY HAVING TO BECOME MUCH MORE
SELECTIVE AS TO THE KIND OF.
PATIENT FOR TRANSPORT TAKING
VERSUS NOT TAKING A MEDICAL
PATIENT. I KNOW COMPANIES THAT
DO THAT. AND ACTION SHOULD MAKE
. OUR CONTINUING DUTIES TO THE
PATIENT. BUT IF WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO PAY OUR EMTS AND PARAMEDICS
AND OTHER EXPENSES WE WILL NOT
STAY FUNCTIONAL. YOUR COMMITTEE
IS IN THE UNIQUE POSITION TO DO
SOMETHING. THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DONE OVER THE LAST TWO DECADES
AND IT'S WAY OVERDUE. MEDICAL
PAID A HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
DOLLARS FOR TRANSPORT A HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN DOLLARS. FOR
TRANSPORT. JUST TO SHOW UP IN
THE AMBULANCE GASTER TODAY COST
. ONE AND FIFTY DOLLARS PLEASE
SUPPORT DECIDED. PLEASE PLEASE
PLEASE RATING THIS RIDICULOUSLY
LOW MEDI CAL RATE SO THAT
COMPANIES LIKE OURS CAN FOCUS ON
DOING WHAT WE NEED TO DO SERVE
OUR PATIENTS THE NEW YORK
CONSTITUENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. REPUBLICAN LINE NUMBER
EACH YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS SHARE DAILY THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS AND SUPPORT OF THE
ALCOHOL DRUG PROGRAM RESIDENTIAL
AND OUTPATIENT LIKE YOU TO COME
BACK BILL THE FUNDING PART IS IN
DEFICIT DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
WHEREIN WE LOST NEARLY FIVE YOUR
DAD WELL OPIOID OVERDOSES HAVE
EXCEEDED COMBAT DEATHS FROM
COUNTY. IMPOSITION OF LICENSURE
FEE INCREASES WILL EXACERBATE
THE LAWSUIT SAYS WE'RE
EXPERIENCING AS THE FEES ARE
TIED TO BAD NUMBERS DURING THE
PANDEMIC PROGRAMS WERE GRANTED
FEE WAIVERS TO KEEP THE DOORS
OPEN AND ARE NOW BEING ASKED TO
PAY THEM BACK WITH A 45%
INCREASE IN LICENSING FEES THIS
IS THE ABSOLUTE WORST TIME TO
PLACE ADDITIONAL BURDENS ON
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE FACING STORE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES. INCREASES
IN OPERATING EXPENSES AND AN
UNRELENTING WAVE OF THE PATIENT
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
FOR BACK WHEN LIFE PUNCHES
STABLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. HELLO
NUMBER A FIVE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN THERE BUT ON TOP OF THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT HERE IN
PRAGUE SUPPORT OF OUR
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL CONTAINED
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND INFORMATION THE
PROPOSAL WOULD FULLY FUND DATA
COLLECTION AND REPORTING BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON IMPACT
BROADBAND EXPANSION ON HEALTH
OUTCOMES AN ACT. OKAY PROVIDERS
INCLUDING HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
ARE CRITICAL PART OF UNITY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HAVE
INCREASINGLY EXPERIENCE PROGRESS
PROBLEMS DELIVERING CARE WAS
LITTLE TO NO INTERNET ACCESS OR
ANY OTHER PATIENTS. OF THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT THERE
EXISTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO COLLECT
THE DATA BETTER INFORMED HOW
HEALTHCARE PARTNERS. THAT ARE
THE KILLERS OF THEIR COMMUNITY
CAN ENGAGE MEANINGFULLY IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES. FOR THESE
REASONS WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
INCLUDE THE PROPOSAL IN THE
FINAL TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE STATE BUDGET. OR ON THE
CONVERSATION LEGISLATURE AND
MINISTRATION ON THE PARK THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIX
COLOR PLEASE. REPORT LINE NUMBER
ONE FOR. ONE FOURTEEN LOT IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ MY REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE
SUPPORT MANY OF THESE PROPUBLICA
AND ONLY GOING TO FOCUS ON THE
BILL CAN PASS THE FOR MASTERS OF
SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS PROPOSAL-
AND BEND OREGON AND I KNOW YOU
KNOW THAT IS PATIENTS IN
ADDITION FOR THE LIFE OF
WORKFORCE AND THAT'S W. LEVEL
SOCIAL WORKERS. DELIVERY
SERVICES ACROSS THE DIVERSE BACK
IN PROGRAM. THAT IMPACT
VIRTUALLY EVERY CALIFORNIA. MSW
LEVEL STAFFER CRITICAL IN
SERVING INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
AND HACKED BY POVERTY ABUSE
NEGLECT AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS AND DEATH INCLUDES MANY
PUBLICLY FUNDED PROGRAMS AND
CHILD WELFARE FOSTER CARE THAT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES EDUCATION
HOSPITAL. OKAY PADDING AND
FORTUNATELY THERE ARE JUST NOT
ENOUGH WHAT. WILL OF SOCIAL
WORK- AND BECAUSE OF THAT THERE
IS FIERCE COMPETITION ACROSS
GOVERNMENT AND NON GOVERNMENT
AGENCY TO EMPLOY. MSW PROGRAM IN
ADDITION WE GROWING BECAUSE OF
POOR STUDENTS TO WORK FOR
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. SUCH
AS INDIVIDUALS OF COLOR AND
THOSE LIVING WITH DISABILITIES
AND THIS PROPOSAL DOES HAVE
SUPPORT FOR SEX STUDENTS BECAUSE
THE NEED FOR DIVERSE SOCIAL
WORKERS- COMMUNITY BASED ERRORS
IS CRUCIAL. I'M HERE FOR YOUR
TIME AND I. APOLOGIZE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE WILL BOTTOM LINE
NUMBER ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
ALL. NUMBER EIGHT LOOK AT THAT
AMOUNT YOUR THIRD PERSON PAMELA
YOU HAVE A COMMENT LOOK LETTER.
THE FAMILIAR YOU ALMOST BY THE
BY SPOKE ON THE FIFTH. MEDICAL
MICHAEL. L. A. AVE IF THE
PROPOSED CAN LITTLE BIT MORE
PEOPLE IF YOU GET A- CONNECT THE
TOTAL AT YOU'RE LOOKING. BEFORE
YOU GO TO BUT I'M NOT. HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO OFFER BECAUSE- ARE UP
WITH THE- STATE ALONG YOU TO IF
THE COMMITTEE CAN LOOK. FOOTBALL
FIFTEEN FEBRUARY NOT PLEASE
ALLOW FOR THIS. BEFORE WORLD WAR
THANK THANK YOU FOR MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. SUPPORT THE END
OF THAT. PROVIDE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THE COLOR VALUE AT THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP AND THE
METABOLIC BECAUSE WE WERE
TALKING COULD NOT BE FOUND
NETWORK. NEARLY FORTY OR- FIVE I
REQUEST. THAT MORNING. FOR
NONVIOLENT. OF PEOPLE SPEAK OR
HELP EVEN. OKAY MAN YOU BE
NEEDED INCLUDING WITH ONLY
PROPOSAL WILL LOCK TO FIX.
INNOVATOR A LIPSTICK HEALING
BETTER TO PREPARE ANY I COULD
NOT BE THANKS FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ALSO ONE
PLEASE I. VENTURA THIS STATE ARE
WITHIN OUR ONE PROVIDERS ALLY.
YOU CAN IN SUPPORT OF MEDICARE
INCREASE BRAIN MINISTRY- COMING
ONE OF LARGEST PROVIDERS IN THE
STATE OF. I CAN TELL YOU THE AND
HAS BRO OUR STAFF IN THIS. AND
THIS IS A VITAL NEEDED IN ORDER
ENSURE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE.
ADEQUATE COVER AS WELL AS BEEN
TO OUR EMAIL PERIM. AND NURSES
WHO HAVE DROUGHT AND THEN. ROSE
TO THE TIME TIME AGAIN TO SERVE
OUR COMMUNITIES- THERE'S JUST NO
WAY FOR US TO CONTINUE TO KASHIF
PRIVATELY INSURED PATIENTS TO
MEET THE DEMAND THAT WE HAVE TO
RAISE THE WAGES GREAT BENEFITS
SO THAT WE CAN ATTRACT THE
WORKFORCE NOT ONLY NOW BUT- INTO
THE FUTURE WE RISK- FUTURE
STAFFING ISSUES THAT WILL HAVE
A- DEVASTATING IMPACT ON THE
STATE. IF WE CANNOT SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AND THE SOLUTION TO THAT
INVESTMENT ACCOUNT INCREASE THAT
WE SO DESPERATELY NEED- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING IT TO
THE ATTENTION TODAY AND
DISCUSSING IT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ASSISTING YOU. AS THIS
PROGRESSES THROUGH. AWESOME
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLORFUL. WE'RE GOING TO LINE
ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THEN MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS FAMILIAR
HELLO AND I REPRESENTING THE
FARMERS NEIGHBORHOODS- ANY OF
CHULA VISTA AND I'M CALLING HERE
DAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE-
OPEN ACCORDING NEIGHBOR AND YOU
VERY SERVICES CRAFT FOR. AND I
THOUGHT SUPPORT FUNDING I
BELIEVE ALSO OF THEM SHOULD HAVE
RECORDS THEY NEED TO THRIVE BY.
THE FACT THAT MY NEIGHBORHOOD
HAVE YOU FORCES TO ENSURE KIDS-
FIX EITHER GOALS AND VALUES
PROVIDED PROPERTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND-
MODERATOR LET'S TAKE A QUICK.
RECESS AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
I AM READY ALL RIGHT YOU WILL.
WE WILL START OFF WITH THE WIND
ONE FORTY ONE BEFORE I. BRIAN
WANTED ONLY ONE LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN MY NAME- I LATEST
FRIDAY OF FALLEN HERE L. R. L.
A. I REQUEST. AND I HAVE BEEN A
LONG TIME RESIDENT THRILL OF IT
AND I HAVE HUNDREDS UNIT HAS
BENEFIT YES I'M LONELY BROWN'S
LIKE LEADERS COLLEGE EVERY IN
THE FIGHT FOR HARPER. WITH THE
CASE THAT THEY GET A- SALINITY
GARDEN THAN ONE OF MY FAVORITE
IN WILL NEVER ARE HEALTHY.
FOR UP TO THREE THE L. THING IS
THE FACT LIVER OVERWEIGHT IN
FACT HE AND ALL OF. I AM
INTERESTED TO COMMITTEE PROGRAMS
EARLY WORK ON AND I WILL FIFTY.
THE REPORT FROM THE- GENERAL. TO
CONTINUE WITH THE- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLOR PLEASE. WE HAVE A LINE
TWENTY EIGHT MY NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT ZERO THANK. BUT SOMEBODY
NOW GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I REPRESENTING
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD COMMUNITY
HELLO THIS TO RESIDENT AND
PARENT. ARE YOUR CHILDREN IN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL I'M CALLING HERE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COORDINATED
NEIGHBORHOOD AND COMMUNITY
SERVICE THE GRANT PROGRAM UNDER
ISSUE TWELVE TODAY. HAVE A LONG
TERM PARENT AND RESIDENTIAL
EFFECT STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING BECAUSE I
CARE ABOUT MY NEIGHBORHOOD AND I
EIGHTEEN FIRST HAND THE TYPE OF
SUPPORT FUNDING LIKE THIS CAN DO
FOR OUR COMMUNITY. FEDERAL
FUNDING OF FEDERAL TO SUNSET THE
HERE BUT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR CHILDREN MORE. THAN
EVER AN INCH. YOUR PROPERTY-
AFTER DAVID FUNDS ARE THAT NEED
THE MOST THROUGH THE COORDINATED
NAY AND SERVICE GRANT PROGRAM
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLOR PLEASE. WE HAVE ONE NUMBER
FORTY EIGHT. FORTY NINE I
APOLOGIZE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR NAME YES WE CAN.
HI MY NAME IS MONICA AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF BOYLE HEIGHTS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I'M CALLING
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE REQUEST
FOR TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND.
YOUR QUESTIONS BY THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE RESTORATIVE
CARE VILLAGE THE RESORT OF
CARAVELLA TO THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY THAT HAS A LOT OF
COMMUNITY INPUT IN ON BEHALF OF
MY COMMUNITY I WANT TO UPLIFT
THE EXCITEMENT THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED FOR THE IMPROVE HEALTH
CARE LINKAGES TO COMMUNITY
SERVICES THAT WILL COME FROM
THEIR START OF EVIDENCE. MODEL
PROVIDE CARE TO PATIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AT THEIR MOST
VULNERABLE TIMES OF CRISIS DUE
TO MENTAL HEALTH THANK YOU FOR
HOMELESSNESS THIS PROJECT IS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT REGIONAL
RESPONSE TO THE CHALLENGES THAT
ARE HARMING OUR FAMILIES OUR
NEIGHBORS AND OUR COMMUNITY THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
NEIGHBORHOODS MANY OF WHICH HAVE
BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE COLD AT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IN
INVESTMENTS CORRECT CARINGBAH
SERVICE TO FOR MOLD NUMBER.
THANK YOU AT THE EMAIL CENTER.
THE ANYTHING THE KERN SERVICES
IN TERMS PARKING. WILL ENSURE
THE APPROACH LEVEL CARE FOR ALL
PATIENTS TO HELP. THE MEMBER
PRESS TO REENTER SOCIETY WITH
THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NICE COLOR
PLEASE. THE NEXT PROBABLY WILL
VOTE THE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TERRY ONLY
WITH ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION CALLING FOR AN APPROACH
AUTHOR OF THE CALIFORNIA SUCCESS
OPPORTUNITY ACADEMIC RESILIENCE
GUARANTEED INCOME FOR STUDENTS
PROGRAM UNDER ITEM TWELVE
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD DISRUPT THE
CYCLE OF POVERTY BY PROVIDING A
FIVE MONTH GUARANTEED INCOME TO
GRADUATING SENIORS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THOUSAND EACH YEAR
HUGE FINANCIAL OBSTACLES THAT
THEY TRY TO ATTEND COLLEGE OR
START A CAREER AND WHILE THE
VAST MAJORITY WANT TO GO TO
COLLEGE ONLY ABOUT 50% ACTUALLY
ROLL. FIVE MONTHS OF GUARANTEED
INCOME OF THE DEMONSTRABLE
FOOTING SO THEY CAN PURSUE THEIR
GOALS. RICHARD I GUARANTEED
INCOME SHOWS THAT IT'S VERY COST
EFFECTIVE PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS WHICH HELPS THEM BECOME
ECONOMICALLY STABLE THEY CAN
MOVE AHEAD. WE CAN PROVIDE THIS
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS YOUTH GIVING THEM
AGENCY AND SUPPORT TO CHART A
BETTER FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES.
THERE YOU INCLUDED EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THIS IMPORTANT PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COLOR PLEASE. THE BOTTOM
LINE OF ONE YOU KNOW I'M- ONE
ELEVEN PEOPLE HAD. MY NUMBER ONE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GIVE ME A
MEMBERS HAPPY SECTOR-LIMÓN
DONALD WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION I'M
CALLING TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
ME- ITEMS FOR INVESTMENT THE NSW
CAPACITY BUILDING PROGRAMS. ON
THAT AND THEY AFFECT YOU ALSO
SPOKE TO EARLIER AND THE PUBLIC
GUARDIAN PUBLIC CONSERVATIVE
PROGRAM SUNDAY BOTH OTHER ITEM
TWELVE ALSO REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER THREE THE CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES I CAN'T REVIEW
WE HAVE THE CONVICTION OF THE
CPP BUT I WANT TO KNOW THE
INTERSECTION OF THIS REQUEST
WITH SEVERAL OF THE BUDGET
REQUEST THE CHEERLEADING HAS PUT
FORTH. HELLO WATER STATE WE NEED
TO FACE SUPPORTER LEADERSHIP
PROVIDER RATE OF PLACEMENT AND
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
IN OUR CARE. BEEN ABLE COUNTY TO
AVOID OVERSEAS AND EMERGENCY
PLACE AND AFTER A FEW KEY THAT
OTHER PLACE FOR CHILDREN OF ALL
AGES. THE LEGISLATURE HAS
SUPPORTED NUMEROUS PRIOR EFFORTS
TO EXPAND PLAY FROM FROM
SERVICES THAT HAVE YET TO BE
IMPLEMENTED BY THE STATE
EXAMPLES ABOUND IN THE MEANTIME
COUNTY THE LOSING PLAY FIRST AND
HAVING GREATER. SECURING NEEDED
SERVICE THAT. WE ALWAYS. FOR
GREATER. FOR CAL. BUT FOR THE
FIRST WE'VE ASKING FOR IN CASES
OUT FOR YOU ABOUT TO FOR A- WE
VENTURE TO SAY. THE YOUR
CHILDREN THE BE AND IT HAS
BETWEEN. TO BE PEOPLE AT. WE CAN
BILL THE CITY A TWO WAY STREET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LOOKS COLOR PLEASE. REPORTER I
NEVER THE PGA. BUT YOU'RE A
MEMBER THANK YOU MUCH FOR THE
TODAY- AMBER SHE WITH THE
CARROTS HEALTH DIRECTORS OF CAL
. CALLING IN SICK OF TWO
PROPOSAL FIRST BEING FUNDING OF
THE PUBLIC GUARDIAN WITH THE
RIVER YOUR FOR WATER AND THEN
THE SECOND BEING THE BACK ROW OF
RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT SEG
LICENSOR FUND PROPOSAL WHICH. WE
OFFER. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YOU
HAVE MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY ONE
BASEBALL HAD. MY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT FINE
WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWELVE
MY NUMBER OF YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CRENELLATED WITH
THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER CALLING
ON BEHALF OF ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN- WE WANT TO THANK THE
SENATE FOR INCLUDING CHILD CARE
IN ITS PRIORITIES. LEADING
FAMILY FEED EVERY THIRTY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR BRING HIM TO PARENTS
ABOUT PRISON APPLICATION WHILE
ENSURING HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
ARE PAID IN FULL AND ECONOMIC.
RECOVERY OF CALIFORNIA IS
INCLUSIVE OF WOMEN OF COLOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS COLOR PLEASE. WE HAVE
ABOUT FIFTY FIVE IN THE QUEUE
BILL. AND WE WILL GO NEXT TO MY
NUMBER ONE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS A NEW PAIR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND
MARVIN BEYOND COMMON SENSE
MEDIA. BEER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE SIX MILLION DOLLAR QUEST FOR
THE EMPOWERMENT PROGRAM. THAT
WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO PUBLIC
SERVICES- CALIFORNIA. THANKS SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE WILL GO TO THE
HOME RUN HERE. WE WILL BOTTOM
LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MANAGING KENNER AFTER
JUST A SHORT. SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY I'M CALLING FOR THE
PROPOSAL TO BUILD CAPACITY FOR
NSW PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY FOR THE
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS TO DIRECTLY
SUPPORT STUDENTS THEIR
EDUCATIONAL FIVE. I CAN OFTEN
VERY LIMITED FOR GRADUATE
STUDENTS. WERE OFTEN FORCED
EITHER TAKE ON AMEND THAT AS I
HAVE DONE OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS OR SOMEHOW JUGGLE A FULL
TIME JOB. THE PART TIME UNPAID
INTERNSHIP AND A FULL COURT.
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE ALSO
PARENTS OR CAREGIVERS. ARE
THEREFORE ESPECIALLY WORKING
READ FULL TIME JOB AS THEY TRY
TO EARN THEIR AND THAT'S A B.
THE FOURTEENTH NINE FINANCIALLY
IF HE THE BUILDING AND DIVERSE
FIND. FOR ADDITIONALLY
UNIVERSITIES COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS OR RESOURCES OR
DEVELOP FACILITATE EFFECTIVE AND
EQUITABLE SOCIAL WORK TRAINING
PROGRAM THANK YOU. CALLER PLEASE
. THANK YOU FOR EIGHTY FOUR LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR. MY NAME IS
GENEVIEVE FLORES HARO AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NETWORK SPONSORED
INSTRUCTS THE PORT OF THE BUDGET
REQUEST FOR EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
SUPPORT INNOVATIVE APPROACHES TO
AND DOMESTIC. SIX AND SIX.
THIRTY WITH THAT WORK WAS FIRST
PUBLISHED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TO
SHARE LEARNINGS AND INNOVATIONS
IN THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FILLED
IN TO ENSURE UNDERSERVED
VICTIMS- THE I'LL HAVE ACCESS TO
NEEDED SERVICES ARE TWENTY
MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS ARE
CULTURALLY GROUNDED AND
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE NONPROFITS
ARE REPRESENT THE MOST
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA SUCH AS MONOLINGUAL
SPEAKERS. IMMIGRANTS THE DEATH
COMMITTEE AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN
AND IF CALIFORNIANS WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE LEGISLATORS
SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF
EIGHTEEN MILLION IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET TO FUND ACCOUNT. SOCIAL
SERVICES TO SUPPORT ANOTHER
SOCIALLY ROOTED APPROACHES TO
AND IN THE AND VIOLENCE THE YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE NEXT. ACTUALLY LOCAL LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY TWO. BY NUMBER
SEVENTY CAN YOU MIGHT HAVE A
VENUE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'RE
SORRY WE WERE BONUS YOU LINE.
ONE OH FIVE. ONE OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MY NAME IS WILLIAM. PRESIDENT
CEO OF THE SOUTHERN CHRISTIAN
LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE ALL USED
TO SUPPORT IN THE CLOSELY
INTEGRATED PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
RATHER REALLY FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE AND
THEY SO NEEDED TO BE SERVED
PLEASE PARKS ARE FUNDING. IN
CLINIC WORK. WHO ARE TO THE- OF
OUR- OUR COMMUNITIES GET BETTER
WHEN WE COULDN'T WIN THESE
CLINICS AND WORKERS ARE ABLE. TO
WRECKED THEIR JOB EFFECTIVELY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HAVE MY
OUT I DO WORK WITH THE- DO THIS
MADE A MINUTE AGO ONE A LACK
SYSTEM WITH. AND NO ONE WAS. HER
AND WE COULDN'T UNDERSTAND SHE
COULD NOT AND NO ONE IN THE
PUBLIC I THINK THE NEXT WEEK
WITH THESE VERY INTENTIONAL
DELIVERY ONE CAN ARTICULATE
THEMSELVES HERE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LESS COLOR PLEASE
. THANK CAROLINA NINETEEN
NINETEEN FOUR HAD. AND COMMITTEE
MEMBER I AM QUITE A RUN FOR WITH
AMERICA MEDICAL. AND MARK THE
PRESIDENT AND ASSOCIATION SAN
DIEGO REPRESENTING EIGHT
OUTGOING PROVIDERS. THE CALL
DURING THE FIRST PINE RIDGE
WRITTEN BY RECALL. I DID NOT
HAVE BEEN AT OUR- BASICALLY
THERE ARE A LOT OVERDUE. AND
IT'S PROBABLY OVERDUE BECAUSE
ADVANCED HAVE COME AND UNITED
STATES WIDE EFFORT TO MAKE IT
OUT. WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS
MONUMENTAL I DON'T HAVE LABOR
ADVOCATE STANDING SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER WITH THAT WELL WE'VE
BEEN IMPORTANT OUT. THE NEGATIVE
IMPACT. THEY COME PURSUE HAD ON
THE INDUSTRY AND AREN'T. YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE MANY. YOU CANNOT.
FEATURE EMTS AND WITHOUT THE WAY
. AND IMPROVING WORKING. WE GOT
NEED A MY INCREASE PLEASE VOTE
YES IN SUPPORT OF THE INCREASE
THE- THANK VERY MUCH SIX COLOR
PLEASE. AND WE WILL ALSO NEVER
COME NINE TWENTY YEAR LAW IS
STILL PLEASE VOTE ON. HELLO MY
NAME IS EDGAR LARA FROM BOYLE I
LOS ANGELES COUNTY I AM AND-
JUDGE AT THE MONEY THAT IT WE
CANNOT BELIEVE THAT LITTLE
YELLOW CALLING. IN THE CHILD
INSTEAD BUDGET PROPOSAL HELLO
THAN INDIGENOUS WOMEN LED
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
LANGUAGE JUSTICE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE BY INVISIBILITY PERSON.
MIKE COMMUNITY CALIFORNIA IS
HOME A GROWING OF THE PEOPLE WHO
MIGRATE FROM MEXICO AND CENTRAL
AMERICA. AND IT IS CRUCIAL THAT
CALIFORNIA'S SUPPORT ACCESS TO
RESOURCES FOR THE DIVERSE CITY
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
IMMIGRANT CHILD INSURED
NAVIGATOR WILL HELP FAMILY
ADVOCATE FOR THE RELEASE OF
THEIR YOUNG RELATIVES FROM ALL
OUR R. V. MY PROVIDE LANGUAGE
PRACTICE RESTORE. THE SUBJECT
MATTER. REFER THE HELP THEM
THRIVE ONE THEIR RELATIVES HOW
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK COLOR PLAY- ABOUT MY
NUMBER. SIX THEY THOUGHT. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARION
DONOVAN COLUSA I'M A DIRECTING
ATTORNEY IMMIGRANT FOUNDERS
LAWCENTER. AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE IMMIGRANT CHILD
INTEREST NAVIGATOR BUDGET
PROPOSAL AS WELL. INDEPENDENT
FROM OPEN LEGAL SERVICE TO
IMMIGRANTS SHALL ENOUGH AFFECT
THE YOU FELT FACILITY- THAT'S
WHY AS CHILDREN HAVE BEEN REALLY
IF CERTAIN CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW
FIRST HAND THE BEING HELD IN OR
IF YOU LONGER THAN ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY CAN COST I'M A BIG
CHILDREN. AND THAT THEY SHOULD
BE SAFELY AND QUICKLY. YEAH THEY
CAN NAVIGATOR PROGRAM WHICH HELP
CHILDREN NEED TO COME IN THE
RIYADH I WITH APPROVED BY MORE
QUICKLY ARE ALSO HAVE AN
ATTORNEY WHO REPRESENTS YOU
KILLED ARGUE THATARE THINK THE
PRESIDENT YEAH AND LUNCH WILL BE
WHAT BEFORE THE MONEY TO. OF
NAVIGATOR WITH THE HELP OF
CONNECTED NOT HEALTH SERVICES
AND OTHER RESOURCES THAT WOULD
ENSURE KILL ARE QUICK ENOUGH TO
GET LIFE AND CALL HOME AND
ENGAGE MORE FOR WHAT GRAYSON K.
AND- FRANKLY INTEGRATED PROGRAM.
OR FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTER AND THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE WHICH ARE GENERALLY THE
MOST IN NEED PEOPLE WITH. THANK
YOU OKAY IN THE FINAL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THE BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE THE PHONE ON. THANK
YOU. YEAH NEW MADAM CHAIR MAY
INDICATE MEMBER LEADING AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR EIGHT UNITED
EMS WORKERS HAPPY LOCAL FOUR
NINE ONE. REPRESENT ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED EMS PROFESSIONALS
DROPPED INTO CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING YOUR SUPPORT THE GROUND
AMBULANCE INCREASE AMERICA.
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THE AM
SERVICES INDUSTRY DON'T STOP
TWENTY FOUR HOUR SEVEN DAY A
WEEK CALLING THE REQUIRES
DEDICATED DEDICATION. AND
COMPASSION I THINK YOU HEARD A
LITTLE BIT OF THOSE STORIES
TODAY. WORK MATTERS BECAUSE
THAT'S WORKERS ARE MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN THEIR COMMUNITY
AND ALSO STAND IN A GROVE OF
INTEGRAL COMPONENT OF THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IN WHICH THEY
OPERATE. MEMBERS OF UNITY AND
LYFT WORKERS BELIEVE THAT EVERY
PERSON RESPONDED THAT
COMMUNITIES NEED. THIRTY CAMPUS
HILL THE AMERICAN DREAM BY BEING
ABLE TO AFFORD IT PEOPLE WHO
LIVE WITH IN THE COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH THEY SIR. MAY THE WORKERS
WHO HAD CALLED STARTING. THEIR
YOUNG AND AFTER YEARS. I NEED
PROFESSIONAL THEY'RE LOOKING TO
ESTABLISH LIFE. I ACTUALLY.
ACTUALLY WILL. HELP REDUCE.
TAXES AND LIVE A GOOD LIFE. WHEN
THEY RECEIVE FIFTEEN TO
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR DUE TO
THE CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT RATES
. THEY'RE TRYING THEIR SACRIFICE
. AND THERE THEY WILL WORK
DURING THE RECENT CAN GET MAKE
HAVE TO BE WORTH MORE THAN THAT
. I'M HERE ASKING YOU TO HELP US
MAKE. THE AMERICAN DREAM
POSSIBLE FOR THESE BRIGHT YOUNG
MEN AND WOMEN BY CREATING MEDIC
TOLERATE. THAT EASY M. S.
WORKERS CAN BUILD THEIR LIFE IN
THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY
WORK ANSWER. I CREATING A
REIMBURSEMENT RATE YOU CAN BEGIN
TO PAY BACK OUR MOST DEDICATED
EMS WORKERS COULD BE IMPORTANT
WORK THEY DO DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
I WOULD HAVE. THE PROPOSAL FOR
AN ON CREEK TRAIL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLOR PLEASE
. IN OTHER WORDS THE LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY FOUR THE PHONE HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FILLED WITH
EVEN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF.
AROMATICS SEIU LOCAL FIVE
THOUSAND FOR THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
REPRESENTING FELT WITH THE VA
MUST PROFESSIONAL DEPARTURE
GREAT STATE. FIGHTING FOR FAIR
WAGES SAFE WORKING CONDITIONS
AND A SUSTAINABLE CAREER FOR
THESE OFFER GOTTEN HEROES.
REPORT INCREASINGLY MEDICAL.
RIGHT NOW WITH FIVE EMPLOYERS
THE REVENUE STREAM THE START
AFFECTING THESE COURT FACTORS
ALONGSIDE ADVOCATES LIKE ARE YOU
THE ONLY TRUE FOR THINKING STEPS
WITH THIS MATTER WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER TO A IN THAT AND MAKE
SURE PRESIDENT SHALL APPOINT
RECEIVING THE BEST BUY. BOTH
PRIEST THANK. THANK YOU NICE
COLOR PLEASE. HELLO ABOUT THE
LINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY SIX THE
FIRM HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I AM VERY OFTEN
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF OUR U.
S. IN BALLARD CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
EXPRESSED FOR EIGHTEEN MILLION
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. TO SUPPORT
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES AND
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
VALOR ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF A
STRONG NETWORK OF ADVOCATES
CRISIS PROFESSIONAL VOLUNTEERS
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS THAT MAKE
UP CALIFORNIA STATE THAT BIRTH
PROVIDERS A SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
EIGHTEEN MILLION IS NEEDED FIND
CRITICALLY RESPONSES AND
CULTURALLY SPECIFIC SERVICE
PROVIDERS SHOULD ACTUALLY
INCLUDING FOREIGN AND CURATION
ALONG THE CONTINUUM OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. WHERE WE NEED TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS. AND INTERACT ACTUAL
VIOLENCE AN INVASION AND
RESTORATIVE TRANSFORMATIVE
DRAFTED AND DIFFERENT
ACCOUNTABILITY SUPPORT BEYOND
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REPORT INCLUSION OF
EIGHTEEN MILLION AND THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET FIND A CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES TO
SUPPORT INNOVATION IN ENDING
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL THAT
CURRENT. THANK YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. NEXT
WILL WALK THE LINE NUMBER FIFTY
. CARE EGGMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HI RYAN WALTERS AND I NEED FOR
THE REST OF THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF INFUSION
PARAMEDICS LOCAL THREE SEVEN
ZERO I REPRESENT ONE THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND I CAN GIVE YOU FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS. I DREAMED OF
BECOMING A PERSON WHO DEDICATED
HER LIFE TO HELPING OTHERS AND I
WAS INVOLVED IN A SERIOUS CAR
CRASH RIGHT HOPE AND THERE'S YOU
THINK OF THIS POSSIBILITY. IN
PEACE ASSEMBLY MY DAYS WITH
SADNESS AND FRUSTRATION I DIDN'T
DIDN'T BUDGE. BUT THAT ME I HELP
ALLEVIATE WITH MY LOVED ONE MR
REPORTER THEY A CELEBRATION BUT
I KNOW THE MAKES THE DAY IN THE
LIVES OF ORDINARY PEOPLE AND I
AM SO COMMITTED TO MY JOB. BUT I
CAN'T HELP BUT FEEL UNDERVALUED
CONSIDERING THE WORK THAT WE DO
THE DANGERS THAT WE FACE AND THE
EMOTIONAL BURDEN BE KERRY. MARC
ENOUGH WORKERS MAKE AROUND
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR. INTO
THAT MYCOMPANY BERMAN LEFT AND
2100% THE FEDERAL POVERTY LINE
AND CURRENTLY REVIEWING OFFER
THAT ONLY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN DOLLARS. THE ONE. MISTER
AWAY FROM BEING A POP. THE
COMPANY HAD TO USE THAT
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO PREPARE.
I SPENT FOURTEEN YEARS ON THE
JOB AND OVER THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
HOURS IN THE FIELD AND I MAKE
SIXTEEN TWENTY FIVE AN HOUR. I'M
ABOUT THE FROM THE FATHER IF YOU
DAYS I COULD WALK IN AND OUT
RIGHT NOW AND SEEK HIGHER WAGES
. ASIA LOVE YOUR JOB LET ME DO
MY JOB I WANT TO GET TO WORK
HERE I HAV TO SUPPORT MY FAMILY
THE SUPPORT LEGISLATORS LIKE THE
BANK THE CINEMATIC CAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SO WE CAN
RECEIVE A BETTER WAGE THANK.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING NUMBER
THIRTY ONE. HI CALDERON ACT NINE
MONTHS AND YOU'VE YET YEAH I SEE
YOU AND YOUR TWENTY INCOME THAT
WILL LEAD YOU OUT FOR THAT HE-
HI MY NAME IS NAMRATA. ON
CALLING FROM SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES THEY WORK WITH ME TO
ANYTHING HAD IN THE THAT APPLE
AS PART OF THE CENTER FOR
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES HOWEVER AND
I'M CALLING IN THE FOURTH
IMMIGRANTS CHILD CAN SHIP
NAVIGATOR BUDGET PROPOSAL. YEAH
INDIGENOUS WOMEN LATER
MEDITATION ADVOCATE FOR LANGUAGE
JUSTICE FOR INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
AND THE CREDIBILITY AND
RESOURCES TO INDIGENOUS MIGRANT
COMMUNITY I PART OF THE FIELD
TEAM MADE PROVIDE.
INTERPRETATION FOR MANY. DIGITAL
BELIEVES THAT HAVE MADE THEIR
WAY MY FORGET. IF CHARACTERS IN
LOSS AND- I. EQUITY UNDER
COMPANY TWO WITHIN THE- ARE ARE
CITY WHO- WE BELIEVE HAVE
WITNESSED- IN MARBLE AT THE-
THANK TRY TO NAVIGATE THEM-
ENACTED SERVICE IN. THERE ARE
PREFERRED INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES
AND CALIFORNIA'S VERY DIVERSE
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE.
THE FIRST ACCEPTABLE TO EVERYONE
REGARDLESS OF LANGUAGE AND
LANGUAGE BURKE. IMMIGRANT
ADVOCATES SHOULD NAVIGATE WILL
HELP FAMILIES ADVOCATE FOR THE
RELEASE OF OUR YOUNG RELATIVE
TERMS FOR OUR CUSTODY BY
PROVIDING LANGUAGE ACCESS REPORT
. I AM SUBJECT MATTER. EVERY
FIFTEEN HEALTH AND PRICE ONE THE
RELATIVE OUR HOPE THANK YOU YOUR
- THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
COLOR PLEASE. OKAY THE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE EIGHT MEN AND
THAT TOO MANY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MELISSA HARRIS AND I ENDED
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF AND THE
SERVER AMBULANCE OPERATING
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES AND
ORANGE COUNTY I'M ALL FOR THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS CALIFORNIA
INTERESTED. HERE'S MAYBE THEY
COULD MAKE HONOR DATE BE
SPEAKING TO YOU AS A MEMBER OF
THE FUNDS FIRST RESPONDERS
COALITION. FIFTEEN FOR AN
INCREASE MEDIC HOW GREAT FOR
AMBULANCE SERVICES THE EMS
INDUSTRY IF IN A CRISIS LIKE WE
NEVER SEEN BEFORE WHAT.
CHALLENGES FROM AN ONGOING
PANDEMIC LEADING. CANDIDATE FOR
WRITING INFLATION AND THE LACK
OF FUNDING FROM THE STATE. FOR
THE LAST FIVE YEARS WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED A SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE IN APPLICANTS ARE
TURNOVER RATE FREE HANDOUT MAKE
WITH. RESPECT ONLY. THE LADY
RETAIN AND RECRUIT IAN MASS YOU
HAVE BURKE OUT YES NO PAY DURING
THE BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC IN
THAT HIGH SCHOOLS WERE CLOSED
NATIONAL REGISTRY STOP THANK YOU
KEITH RESULTING IN A WIDE HIGHER. FOR OKAY COOL. ZERO APPLICANTS
ARE NO LONGER SPEAKING A CAREER
. I STARTED MY AN BUSINESS
TWENTY YEARS AGO AND I HAVE
NEVER HAD AN IN IN MEDICARE
RIGHT THAT IT CREATE. POPULATION
GROWTH. ONLY HALF TO DEATH EVERY
TIME WE TRANSPORT MEDICARE PAYS
WE DO IT LOSS I WANT TO DO WHAT
IS BEST FOR MY EMPLOYEES I'M
HERE FIGHTING FOR FAIR RATES FOR
THE CRITICAL SERVICES TO BE
PROVIDED UNDER. MATT IS NOT
ENOUGH OUR STAFF EACH LIVING
WAGES COMPATIBLE WITH TODAY NOT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO HOW DO WE
AS AN INDUSTRY FIFTEEN THE NEXT
GENERATION RECRUITMENT. WE
CANNOT GUARANTEE THEM LIVING
WRITING WAIT. WE NEED AN
INCREASE IN THE STATE'S AND THAT
WE NEED AIRSTAFF MORE INMATES
YOUR METHOD I WILL PULL YOUR
STATE LOCAL. CAREER PATH. FOR
NOW. THE FUTURE R. E. M. STAFF
ARE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
VERY MUCH NEXT CALL PLEASE. WE
WILL NOT BOTH THE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY THREE I HAD. MAJOR EGGMAN
FIRST THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THE NAME OF
THE STREET I AM AN EXECUTIVE.
OFFICE IN OAKLAND AND I ENJOYING
IT AFTER THE TONE THE PROPOSAL
TITLED INCREASING PUBLIC BENEFIT
UTILIZATION UNDER ISSUE OKAY AT
EIGHT EIGHT AND- NAVIGATE AND-
SUPPORT. TO MAKE IT EASIER ME
THE TO FIND A CLEAN NUMBER OF
EIGHT AND FIVE BOTH MEN AND
PUBLIC BENEFITS. ASIAN ALAMEDA
CAN. AND MEANT RENTER RECKLESS
ONE MILLION AND PRIVATE PLAN
EVEN WHICH WE HAVE BEEN TO
SEARCH FORTY CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ARE INCLUDED AND IT
WILL REACH ONE HUNDRED AND
CALIFORNIA ANNUALLY. THIRTY SIX
ALAMEDA. YOU ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS MAYBE THEM AGAIN I AM
SO GRATEFUL FOR THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE COMMITTEE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO RECEIVING
QUESTIONS AND WORKING EITHER IN
GREATER DETAIL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLOR PLATE.
PUBLIC ALAINA. THIRTY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS FAIR I THINK I'M A
MEMBER OF THE SB SIX THIRTY NINE
IMPLEMENTATION WORK GROUP- AND
IF YOU GET TOURNEY AT THE
FACILITY RIGHT CALIFORNIA IN OUR
PAST WORK. CALLING IT. F. AS SIX
THREE NINE WORKGROUPS BUDGET
PROPOSAL BY GIVING OUT THE WAGE
EMPLOYEES FOR PEOPLE WITH THE-
CAL. WE ARE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
THE NATIONWIDE SHIPPED THIS
MEANS THERE'S NOT ONE CLEAR ROAD
MAP THE DIRECTION WE MUST GO.
BUT UTILIZED BOTH INNOVATIVE AND
EVIDENCE BASED STRATEGIES
EFFECTIVE. IN OUR EFFORTS TO
TRANSITION INDIVIDUALS.
PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH THE MOST
COMPLEX THE- OUTER SHELTERED
WORKSHOP. IT YOU COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT. THEREFORE
IT'S VITAL FOR CALIFORNIA. OPAL
APPROACHES BUT THAT OUR
WORKGROUP CAN GATHER DATA
ANALYZE WHAT'S TRULY EFFECTIVE I
THINK PROFIT STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THAT WE
CATHOLIC CREATING THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIX FOUR
PLEASE. NOT AVAILABLE TO LINE.
ONE THIRTEEN. A YEAR ME GO AHEAD
PLEASE. OKAY HI MY NAME IS VERY
BOLD AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THANK GOD FOR HELLO WE ARE
CALLING TO REPORT IN HAD A
NICKEL IT'S A GREAT PROGRAM
SUPPORT FOR QUALIFIED. HEALTH
CENTER IN OUR COMMUNITY. THREE
FOUR LANDING THE BAIT AND MAKE
ME IN A BOOK IT LOOK WHAT I DID
WE ARE HERE AT THE BREAKING
POINT. THE FUNDING WORK WE'RE
HAPPY A RAINY WE NEED GOT THERE
IN THE PROTECT. UP HERE. WALK
DOWN MERGING BUSINESS THAT THE-
NOW WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR- ONE
MARK LOCAL FIVE AT THE AIRPORT
SPEAKING OF THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HIS
NEW CALLER. NEXT HELLO BE LINE
NUMBER ONE WHILE THE I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
REMEMBER MY NAME ANNA KNOCKING
WITH THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHT WE ARE ONE OF
THE SPONSORS OF THE CALIFORNIA.
CASE MANAGEMENT I'M- GIVEN THE
HUMANITARIAN CRISES WE'RE
DEALING WITH TODAY WE ARE ASKING
FOR SUPPORT AND THEN THANKS YOU
HOW THANK YOU MANAGEMENT PILOT
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL NINE MONTHS. MANAGE
SERVICE. THE NEW. YOU S. B.
MANDATORY THE FIRST YOU WE
YOU'RE RIGHT AND UKRAINE HUMAN
VICTIMS AND I'LL DOUBLE UP
SILENCE YOU CAN SHOW WITHIN
AFTER NINE MILLION SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR OVER TWO YEAR DURATION
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA. ALSO
JONES PROPERTIES OF REFUGEES AND
ASYLUM EXACTLY BRING REMARKS
WHAT. KANEMI AND THE SOCIAL
FABRIC OF THE STATE WE ALL KNOW
THE LONGER SUPPORT IS PROVIDED
FOR BETTER THE OUTCOME EXTENDED
CASE MANAGEMENT IN YOUR OREGON
AND COLORADO HAS DEMONSTRATED
THAT ALREADY PATIENTS DIFFERENT
EXTEND MANAGEMENT PROVIDE. EARLY
WITH RESPECT TO THE BEING
FINANCE HEALTH IT'S TRULY TIME
FOR. TO WITH STATE YOU'VE BEEN
GOING POP. TO BE THE NOT EIGHT
STAFF UP AND PROVIDE BUT HE'S
MANAGED WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIX PLEASE. HEY WE HAVE ABOUT
FORTY QC WE WERE BOTH LINE
NUMBER TWENTY IF I HAD. THE
ADDAMS SUBCOMMITTEE MET MY NAME
IS. MEMBERS OF THE LOS CA
HANDLES SEE. WITH WORK PRIVATE
IN THE PROVIDER SIR RATHER LOS
COUNTY COLLECTIVELY WE OPERATE
NEARLY TWELVE HUNDRED AFTERWARDS
IS REPRESENTING PROVIDERS OF ALL
SIZES FROM SMALL FAMILY OWNED
FIRM THE PUBLIC TRADED
CORPORATION. EACH OF US IS READY
TO SERVE. WHEN IT COMES
PROVIDING SERVICES ESPECIALLY IN
AREAS PASSED THE COMPLEXITY OF
LAKE COUNTY ARE MEMBERS OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES NOTICED A SECOND
CHANCE TO GET IT RIGHT. WHAT
THEY'RE RESPONDING TO THE SCENE
CARE ACT TRANSPORTING A CRITICAL
PATIENT WITH SOMEONE'S LOVED ONE
BETWEEN APPOINTMENTS ARE MEMBERS
OF THE PEOPLE WORK READY TO
SERVE. THE COMMITMENT STARTS
WITH THE PEOPLE HIGHER. THE
MEMBERS THAT WE HAVE STRIVE TO
SELECT ONLY THE BEST PEOPLE IN
AFTER THE TRAINING TO KEEP THEM
UP TO DATE BUT OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS EMS EMPLOYMENT HAS
DWINDLED THE IMAP SUPPORT POLES
SMALLER. THE WORK. ONE ARNOLD.
ROTHERFIELD THAT OFFER PAY YOU
CAN'T CONTINUE TO WORK TO OTHER
SUCH BECAUSE WE PAY THE RATES
WILL COME IF SOMEONE PASSION
ABOUT EMS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ATTRACT AND KEEP THEM IN THIS
JOB BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE HERE
BECAUSE WE NEED THAT EVERY DAY
SOMEONE CALIFORNIA AND HELLO
CHRIS WORK FOR THEM TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES AND
WE CAN'T FOR LOSING AMOUNTS
WORKERS WE JUST TAP. TWENTY
THREE YEARS WITHOUT A MEDIC CAL
RATE INCREASE IS HURTING US THE
TIME TO DO THE RIGHT THING TO
RIGHT THIS WRONG TO SUPPORT THE
FIRST RESPONDERS THE STATE OF
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS. TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES THANK YOU. I THINK
YOU'RE MUCH THE- OPERATOR AND
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO GO TILL
FOUR THIRTY AND THEN AFTER THAT
EVERYBODY ELSE CAN JUST SUBMIT A
COMMENT FROM OUR STAFF REMAINS
OPEN AND EAGER TO TAKE ALL THE
COMMENTS BUT IT FOR THE SAKE OF
TIME GOING TO GO TILL FOUR
THIRTY AND THEN THAT WILL BE THE
END. MY FOR TO. PLEASE OKAY THEN
THEN I FIND IS. ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS SHIRLEY
HERNANDEZ I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE MAKE OR MODEL WHAT COMING
THAT THE FOURTH ENHANCE NEXT AND
A BETA PROGRAM AT THE PARK AT
THE EIGHTEENTH AND THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. YEAH IF
YOU COULD PLEASE VERIFY SPENDING
FOR THE NEXT DAY AND THEN
CRITICAL BUDGET CLASS MONTH
FINAL BUDGET THANK YOU MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER. PLEASE LITTLE BOOK THE LIE
NUMBER. EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
KNEW WHAT THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF COMMUNITY HEALTH AGENCIES
COLLEAGUES LOOK FORWARD TO
PROPOSAL REGARDING THE BACKFILL
OF RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER LICENSURE
FINE AND URGED THE LEGISLATURE.
TO SUPPORT THE BUDGET REQUEST
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. DURABLE TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN PEOPLE HAD. HELLO
CHARACTER IT DIDN'T IN THE BIG
HELLO JEREMY IN THE SUB
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
STEVE GROW I BECAME ANY EMPTY
TWENTY YEARS AGO TO HELP THE
ONES THAT NEED. THE DAY OF YOUR
TO ASK FOR YOUR HELP IN
SUPPORTING THE MEDIC CAL RATE
INCREASE FOR THE AMBULANCE
SERVICE. I SERVE AS THE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIAN BILL DISSOCIATION
AND REPRESENT OVER FORTY FIVE
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS I'M ALL FOR
THE FIELD OIL AND BILLS WHICH
COVER SIX AREA COUNTIES AND
IMPACTS OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND
PATIENTS EITHER THROUGH OUR
SERVICE. THANK YOU KNOW
HOSPITALS LIKE ALAMEDA HEALTH.
CARE MEDICAL CENTER DEPEND ON
OURS. TO TAKE YOU OF THEM
FRAGILE VULNERABLE. DECADE THE
LOCAL MANY WE CAN PER. COMBINED
WITH MEDICAL EXPANSION IS
QUICKLY CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO
RECRUIT. AND RETAIN QUALIFIED
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TECHNICIANS IN
THE IMAGE AND PARAMEDICS. THIS
HAVE UNDERMINED IT HAS BEEN A
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT TO OUR
ABILITY TO SERVE THE ONES IN
NEED WITH THE RISING COST ACROSS
EVERY BUDGET LINE. EMPLOYEE
IMPOSSIBLE FOR US. TO PROVIDE
SUSTAINABLE SERVICE AND CREATE
AN ATTRACTIVE PROFESSION
UNFORTUNATELY THIS ISSUE HAS
BEEN BUILDING LONG BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC STARTED. AND NOW
THREATENS TO UNDERMINE THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF OUR EMERGENCY
AND NON EMERGENCY AMBULANCE
TRANSPORTS INFRASTRUCTURE. TO
ADDRESS OUR RETENTION AND
RECRUITMENT ISSUES AND DOES
POSITIVELY IMPACT THE PATIENT'S.
BILL OF. NEW CAL. IT SURE IS A
LITTLE LOOKING WAY FOR GIVERS
NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE. I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO READ OUR
MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT COULDN'T
BE COMPETITIVE WITH THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY. THANK NINE AND
SUPPORT ON. MUCH TAX COLOR
PLEASE. WHAT IS MY NUMBER ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS DONNA THAT
COLIN BUT HE WORKS PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD IT HAS EIGHTY SAY%
AND I'M ALSO A TRUSTEE FOR
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. I'M PROBABLY IN THE
PORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COORDINATED- A NEIGHBORHOOD AND
COMMUNITY SERVICES GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH IS UNDER SECTION TWELVE. I
HAVE WITNESSED FIRST HAND HOW
NEIGHBORHOODS HAVE. WITH THE
FAITH BASED INITIATIVE- HAVE
BEEN TRANSFORMED AND IT REALLY
CAME ALIVE WALDRON AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THIS IS A STATEWIDE
COALITION HAS COME TOGETHER THAT
IS HELPING TO MOVE FAMILIES OUT
OF POVERTY AND WE HAVE THE DATA
TO SHOW IT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO TO MY
NUMBER ONE FIFTY SEVEN. MY
NUMBER ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. EIGHT WE WILL GO TO THE
NEXT FINE WITH NO RESPONSE- LINE
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KIM CARE. I KEPT MONEY
TODAY IS RELATED TO ISSUE
TWELFTH GROUND AMBULANCE MEDIC
OUT WE- REPRESENT THE
ANTICIPATION AWARD FOUND. KNOWN
AS THE A. L. C. FOR MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS THE AOC HAS SERVED
AS A WARNING COUNTY. LOCAL
ANALYSTS INDUSTRY TRADE
ASSOCIATION. REPRESENT SIX
GROUND AMBULANCE SERVICES
OPERATING TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
EMERGENCY AMBULANCES IN ORANGE
COUNTY. THE AOC IS A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE FUND FIRST
RESPONDERS COALITION. CALIFORNIA
IS OUT OF HOSPITAL HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM DISTRICT THE
SOLUTION MUST INCLUDE AN
INCREASE IN MEDICARE RATES FOR
GROUND AMBULANCE SERVICES. I'VE
WORKED IN EMS FOR MORE THAN
FORTY YEARS AND I'VE SEEN A LOT
IN MY CAREER BUT I NEVER SEEN
OUR INDUSTRY IN THIS MUCH
DISTRESS. ANALYSTS SERVICE
INDUSTRY HAVEN'T SEEN RATING
CREASE IN ITS MANY CALORIES
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY NINE.
TWENTY THREE YEARS AGO ORDER OF
THE CENTURY THE SEVEN EXTREME
RISE IN INFLATION STAFFING
SHORTAGES AND SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES HAVE DRIVEN A ONCE STABLE
INDUSTRY. THANK CURRENT MEDICARE
RATES ARE NO LONGER ADEQUATE OR
SUSTAINABLE THEREFORE I ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BUDGET ITEM
TODAY YOUR SUPPORT WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA AMBULANCE SERVICES TO
RECEIVE ADEQUATE AND EQUITABLE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES PROVIDER
STAFF OF MEANINGFUL COMPENSATION
AND ALL BOOKKEEPING INTO
SEPARATE COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT
WILL BRING AN END TO OUR- FOR
TODAY. IF YOU WERE IN THE QUEUE
AND DIDN'T GET TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO REACH OUT TO
OUR STAFF WE WELCOME YOUR INPUT
AND WELCOME YOUR- YOUR
SUGGESTIONS AND WE CERTAINLY
HEARD A LOT TODAY ABOUT THE- I
AM. HE'S HIGH RATES OF
REIMBURSEMENT OF WE MADE NOTE OF
ALL OF THOSE THINGS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE NOTE OF ANY
OTHER CALLS OR SUGGESTIONS THAT
WE GET AND THAT WILL CONCLUDE
THE BUDGET SUB THREE MEETING FOR
TODAY.